THE.
SUB FIVE COMMITTEE OF THE
BUDGET IS NOW CALL TO ORDER.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE ROLL CALL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WEBER HERE
JONES SAWYER PRESIDENT LACKEY
THERE MELENDEZ
STONE.
THEY WE HAVE A QUORUM.
TO BEGIN THE MEETING WITH THE
ITEMS THAT ARE VOTE ONLY ITEMS.
THE MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT PRESENT
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO VOTE.
AT THE END OF THE MEETING BUT
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HANDLE EACH ONE OF THESE ITEMS
THAT ARE VOTE ONLY ITEMS FIRST.
OF THEIR TWELVE ITEMS OF THAT
HAVE BEEN.
THAT WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT WE
VOTE ON TODAY.
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO THE OTHER
ITEMS WHICH HAVE DISCUSSION.
WILL BEGIN WITH A VOTE ONLY
ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA COURTS WATER REGISTRY
TO APPROVE HIS BUDGET A ROLL
CALL.
WEBER I.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE THAT'S THREE TO
OF THREE DID ZERO WITH THAT.
HAVE MEMBERS THAT.
WHO ARE NOT PRESENT WILL GET AN
OPPORTUNITY VOTE WITH THAT WILL
HOLE OPEN BUT IT IS DOES PASSED?
WILL HOLD OPEN FOR THE BOOK FOR
THEM TO VOTE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO. I'LL VOTE ONLY
ITEM FOR CALIFORNIA CADET CORPS
EXPANSION OF THIS IS A
RECOMMENDATION TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL.
BROKAW.
WEBER NO.
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY QUALITY.
MELENDEZ STONE OKAY THAT'S A TWO
ONE WILL I HAVE TO OF TO REJECT
THE PROPOSAL WE WILL.
HOLD THAT OPEN AND THAT ITEM IS
STILL HELD OPEN.
VOTE ONLY ITEM NUMBER THREE
WHICH IS A MILITARY DEPARTMENT
AT THE CALIFORNIA PORTERVILLE
ó MILITARY INSTITUTE TO PROVE
THE POSITION AND REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY AND REJECT THE GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATIONS. ROLL CALL.
WEBER I JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE TIBET'S AT THREE
TWO ZERO VOTE.
THAT PASSES BUT WILL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS ANTI
TRUST WORKLOAD FOR THE DOJ TO
PROVE ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION.
AND NINE POSITIONS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ON GOING ROLL
CALL. WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OKAY THAT IS A TWO ONE VOTE WE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN OF OF MEMBERS.
THAT IS ON CALL.
A VOTE ITEM NUMBER FIVE ISSUE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WITH THE BUREAU
OF GAMBLING CONTROL THAT THE DOJ
TO APPROVE ONE POINT SIX MILLION.
FROM THE GAMMA CONTROL FUND TO
SUPPORT TWELVE POSITIONS FOR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ONLY
ROLL CALL WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE. LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE THAT PASSES THREE
ZERO WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENTEE MEMBERS TO VOTE. OUT
ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
.
SPRING FINANCE LETTER TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT TO DAM SAFETY FUNDING
FOR THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO APPROVE HIS BUDGET.
BROKAW WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY. MELENDEZ STONE IF IT
PASSES THREE ZERO WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO
VOTE. OF VOTE ITEM NUMBER ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN THE SPRING FINANCE
LETTER CHILD VICTIM OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING FUND FOR THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO PROVE
HIS BUDGET. ROKAHR WEBER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OKAY THAT IS A THREE OH VOTE
IT'S IT'S PASSES WITH WILL HOLD
IT OPEN FOR ABSENTEE MEMBERS. OF.
VOTE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS
THE SPRING FINANCE LETTER
RELOCATION OF THE RED MOUNTAIN
COMMUNICATIONS SITE FOR THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
APPROVE AS BUDGET. ROLL CALL
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE.
LACKEY.
LIKE.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
GO THAT'S FOUR VOTES FOR ZERO
WILL.
THAT PASSES WILL HOLD IT OPEN
FOR.
.
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
OF VOTE I DIDN'T ISSUE NUMBER
NINE ADOPT THE PROVISIONAL
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REGARDING
COURT HOLDING FACILITIES ROLL
CALL. WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT'S FOUR ZERO THAT PASSES SO
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS TO VOTE. OF VOTE ITEM
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER NINE WHICH IS
A DOT THE PROVISIONAL TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE REGARDING THE
COURT FEES SUNSET EXTENSION
BROKAW.
EXCUSE.
NUMBER TEN I'M SORRY ISSUE
NUMBER TWO AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE IF THAT'S TWO TWO THAT'LL
BE HELD OPEN.
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO VOTE.
VOTE I AM ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN
BILL LANGUAGE TO GUIDE THE
SUNSET EXTENSION TO COUNTY TO
COUNTY TRANSFER OF INMATES.
BROKAW WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY. MELENDEZ.
STONE PHILIPPOUSSIS FOUR ZERO
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS TO VOTE.
THAT PASSES VOTE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WHICH IS A DOT THE
PROVISIONAL TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REGARDING THE TECHNICAL
CLEAN UP OF AB FORTY ONE.
CHAPTER SIX NINETY FIVE STEPS TO
TWO OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN BROKAW.
WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY VOTED.
MELENDEZ.
TWELVE.
OKAY SO THAT'S TWO VOTES TWO
ABSTENTIONS WILL HOLD IT OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY.
THOSE OF THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS
THAT WE HAVE THE TWELVE ITEMS I
THINK WITH MELINDA ISSUE CAME IN
AT NUMBER EIGHT SO YOU WANT TO
SEVEN WITH AUTHORED RIGHT NOW
VERY QUICKLY FOR YOU. BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU INTO THE MEETINGS.
OKAY THAT'S ITEM ISSUE NUMBER
ONE THE CURRENT VOTE IS.
THREE ZERO THREE ALSO.
LOCAL MELENDEZ.
OKAY.
AND WAS A STONE STILL NOT HERE
I'D ISSUE ITEM NUMBER TO THE
CALIFORNIA CADET CORPS EXPANSION
THEM.
WE REJECT THE PROPOSAL SO IT IS.
KNOWS IT TOO AND.
WE HAVE ONE I.
WELL I'M SORRY.
YES.
YEAH WELL I'M SORRY WE'RE GOING
TO DO THAT ONE AGAIN BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S KIND OF MISLEADING.
THIS THE PROPOSAL IS TO REJECT
THE PROPOSAL OKAY THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO REJECT
WITHOUT TO DO THAT AYE ISSUE
NUMBER TWO OVER.
THAT.
AND I VOTERS TO REJECT
OKAY SO LET'S DO IT AGAIN.
I'VE VOTERS TO REJECT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL TO NOT FUND THE
CALIFORNIA CADET.
EXPANSION.
OKAY WEBER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY BY.
MELENDEZ.
YES.
THEN YOU SPEND YOUR VOTE NO.
OKAY.
SO THAT PASSES THREE ONE.
A.
OKAY IF YOU VOTE YES YOU.
YOU SAY WE'RE NOT GOING GIVE UP
YEAH WELL I DON'T GIVE A MONEY
IF YOU VOTE YES IF YOU WANT THEM
TO GET MONEY YOU VOTE NO.
I WOULD
YES AND NO UP AT THIS WHAT I
THOUGHT OKAY SO. ANYWAY IT'S
THREE IS TO TWO AND WILL LET
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE LAST
MEMBER TO VOTE OKAY. A ISSUE
NUMBER THREE.
.
YES YES.
MELENDEZ.
OKAY THAT MAKES IT NOW THREE TO
ONE.
I WOULD ALSO KNOW BUTCHER.
OKAY SO WHICH ISSUE THANK YOU I
AM ISSUE NUMBER FOR. A WHICH IS
THE DOJ WORKLOAD FUNDING.
MELENDEZ.
OKAY SO THAT MAKES IT GO TO.
TWO TWO ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR OKAY
SO WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE.
WE'VE ALL OKAY BOGUS.
OKAY SO THAT'S FOUR ZERO.
AND ISSUE NUMBER SIX.
MELENDEZ.
BUT MAKES FOR ZERO OKAY AND
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN.
MELENDEZ.
OKAY THAT MAKES FOUR ZERO SO
THOSE ITEMS OF ALL PASSED AND WE
HAVE TWO LEFT OPEN OKAY THAT
HAVE NOT PASSED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OWE YOU A.
I KNOW YOU GOT SOME MORE
COMMITTEE MEETING SITS THANK YOU.
.
THAT BRINGS US TO THE ITEMS THAT
ARE TO BE HEARD TODAY THE FIRST
ONE IS THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
ALL I BUT I'M SORRY I'M SORRY WE
HAVE A GROUP OF PEOPLE OUTSIDE
WHO HAD BEEN. LISTED JONES
SAWYER IS RECOMMENDATION FIRST
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER.
THREE ITEM WOULDN'T TAKE ITEM
NUMBER THREE FIRST BECAUSE AN
AWFUL LOT OF THE OUTSIDE ON THE
FLOOR WAITING FOR THIS ITEM TO
BE HEARD. AND WILL MAKE SURE
THAT WILL. THEN BUT THAT'LL
BELIEVE SOME OF THE ROOM FOR
OTHERS TO BE ABLE TO BE. TO
PURCHASE RATE SO IT ITEM NUMBER.
FOR.
ITEM NUMBER THREE INVESTMENT IN
LOCAL.
GIVE US YOUR NAME.
AND WILL BEGIN THIS WITH THIS IS
THE ITEM NUMBER THREE UNDER THAT
IS ITEMS TO BE HEARD DAY.
AND.
.
THIS WILL GIVE YOU THREE
INVESTMENT FUND.
YES OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I I AM HERE.
TO REQUEST A HUNDRED MAKE.
DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH
YOU REINVESTMENT FUND.
WHICH WILL ALLOW COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN WERE
CULTURALLY. RELEVANT.
DRAMA INFORMED SERVICES OUTSIDE
OF THE JUSTICES.
THIS IS MY FOURTH TIME SEEKING
FUNDS TO ADDRESS TO TRAUMA THAT
OUR CHILDREN ARE SUFFERING.
I QUITE LIKE I WILL NOT GIVE UP
UNTIL WE MAKE SOME KIND OF
INVESTMENT.
BECAUSE THE LOCKING UP OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE REALLY IS NOT THE ANSWER.
AND TWENTY SIXTEEN OF THE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SIX
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND YOU DIRECTED
ARRESTED. MORE THAN FORTY THREE
THOUSAND YOUTH
WERE ARRESTED FOR MISDEMEANORS.
STATUS OF STATUS OFFENSES
THINGS LIKE PETTY THEFT SCHOOL
FIGHT SMOKING MARIJUANA RUNNING
AWAY AND VIOLATING CURFEW.
HOW DO WE JUSTIFY?
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE
ARE SPENDING BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED
TO THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
KEEP A KID.
LOCKED UP FOR THINGS LIKE THAT.
EVEN THOSE FORTY THREE THOUSAND
KIDS OUT OF THE SYSTEM WILL SAVE
US.
OVER ONE YEAR.
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
BILLION
DOLLARS.
THE HOUSTON VESTMENT
FUND PROPOSED PROPOSALS BROKEN
UP IN THE FOLLOWING MANNER.
SEVENTY FIVE BILLION TO FUND
LOCAL DIVERSION PROGRAMS FOR AT
RISK YOUTH.
FIFTEEN MILLION TO HIGHER SOCIAL
WORKERS IN PUBLIC DEFENDER
OFFICES TO SUPPORT CASES WHERE
MINORS ARE ARRESTED.
AND PROSECUTED IN I THE JUVENILE
OR CRIMINAL COURT DEPENDING ON
THE NEEDS OF THE OFFICE.
AND THEN ANOTHER TEN MILLION
A FUN TRIBAL DIVERSION PROGRAM
FOR NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH USING
TRAUMA INFORMED. COMMUNITY BASED
AND HEALTH BASED INTERVENTION
VENGEANCE.
WITH ME WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT.
TODAY IS FRANKIE GOOD MA OF THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
SHANE MURPHY GOLDSMITH OF THE
LIBERTY HILL FOUNDATION.
AND COMMANDER.
GERALD WOULD YA WOODYARD.
OF THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND MISTER BOOZE LIKE IT'S OUR
FIRST BEEN.
MISSED
BOTH SMITH AND THEN IT WILL HAVE
TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
.
SO UP.
MY NAME'S FRANK IN I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
JUSTICE INITIATIVE AT THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
OR I HAVE BEEN.
FOCUSED ON ENDING THE PRACTICE
THE PROSECUTING YOUTH ADULTS ARE
REDUCING. OUR RELIANCE OUR STATE
RELIANCE ON INCARCERATION TO
DEAL WITH YOUNG PEOPLE WHILE
ALSO BUILDING NOW HELP BASED AND
AND COMMUNITY BASED ALTERNATIVES
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN EFFECTIVE
FOR FOR THIS POPULATION. TO
PROMOTE POSITIVE OUTCOMES AND
REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND IS WHAT
THAT SAID THAT I CAN I'D LIKE TO
JUST AND THE FACT THAT I'M VERY.
HONOR TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT
THIS AYE YOU THREE INVESTMENT
FUND WHICH IT WOULD.
ALLOCATE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FORGET THAT VERSION BUT
THE FOCUS ON A NATIVE AMERICAN
YOUTH. AS WELL AS TO SUPPORT
SOCIAL WORKERS AND PUBLIC
DEFENDER OFFICES.
OF THE REASON WHY DO THIS WORK
AND WHY I BELIEVE IN THIS IN
THIS BILL IT BECAUSE AMOUNT
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT.
AS A YOUNG PERSON ON MY FIRST
OFFENSE THAT WAS ARRESTED IN AND
COMMITTED TO THE YOUTH AUTHORITY
WITH THE FIFTEEN YEAR SENTENCE.
ARE IN A WITH A BIT OF.
YOU KNOW WHAT I WOULD SAY YOU
KNOW GOING INTO INTO THAT
SITUATION I CAME WITH A LOT OF
OF OF TRAUMA YOU KNOW I I WAS
EXPERIENCE DEVELOPMENT FAMILIES
DIVORCE HOMELESSNESS DELIGHT
INCARCERATION OF MY BROTHER. A
LOT OF COMMUNITY VIOLENCE.
AND ALL OF THAT TOOK A TOLL ON
YOU KNOW AND AND AND ULTIMATELY
LANDED ME. IN IN IN IN IN
CUSTODY AND WHAT I CAN TELL YOU
FROM THAT EXPERIENCE IS
INCARCERATION ONLY MAYBE WORSE.
I DIDN'T REALLY ADDRESSED ANY OF
THE UNDERLYING NEEDS THAT WERE
THAT AFFECTED ME. AYE AND LET ME
ON THAT PATH AND IT WAS ACTUALLY
IN SPITE OF THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS IF NOT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT THE STATE INVESTED
IN KEEPING ME INCARCERATED THAT
I GOT OUT. AND FOUND THE HEALTH
IN THE SUPPORT THAT I NEEDED IN
MY COMMUNITY THROUGH THE FAITH
COMMUNITY SPACES. AND AN
AUTHENTIC COMMUNITY LEADERS WITH
QUALITY SERVICES THATHELP ME
BELIEVE IN MYSELF WHEN I YOU
KNOW I HAVE TO SAY I HAD TO
BORROW THEIR CONFIDENCE IN ME
BEFORE I HAD ANY CONFIDENCE IN
MYSELF.
UP AND AND YOU KNOW TODAY YOU
KNOW MY IT IN MY LEGAL
PROFESSION AND AS WELL AS MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE I CAN SAY
THAT WE HAVE THE STATE KNOW WHAT
WORKS. YOU KNOW THE ADOLESCENT
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT DE THE
CRIMINAL.
JUSTICE RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
INCARCERATION IS BAD FOR ALL
PEOPLE PARTICULARLY FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE. AYE AND IN LOOKING AT
LIFE COURSE AYE TRAJECTORIES THE
GREATEST DETERMINE OF WHETHER A
YOUNG PERSON WILL BE LOCKED UP.
AYE IS NOT WHETHER THEY HAD
PREVIOUSLY COMMITTED A VIOLENT
CRIME OR WHETHER THEY'RE GETTING
INVOLVED.
THE SIMPLE FACT OF HAVING BEEN
INCARCERATED ONCE BEFORE.
AND SO IF WE KNOW THE
INCARCERATION HARM KIDS YOU KNOW
WE REALLY NEED TO DO BETTER
ABOUT FINDING ALTERNATIVES AND
THAT IS WHAT THIS THIS. BUDGET
HERE PRESENT TO PREVENT AN
OPPORTUNITY FIGHT FOR DIVERSION
WHICH EVIDENCE SHOWS IS
EFFECTIVE IN GETTING KIDS OUT OF
THE HARMFUL SYSTEM. OF KNOTTED
INCARCERATION BUT FIFTEEN
INVOLVEMENT CAN BE HARMFUL AND
PUT THEM ON A PATH TOWARDS
HEALTH INSTABILITY.
BUT IT ALSO PLACES.
THEM IN COMMUNITY SETTINGS WITH
SERVICES THAT ARE SHOWN
EFFECTIVE THAT ARE A COMMON FORM
CULTURALLY ROOTED AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
WHICH IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE KIDS.
LEARN DIFFERENTLY THAN THAN
ADULTS DO WHEN THEY NEED
TREATMENT THAT IS TAILORED TO
THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS IF SOMEONE
UP PLEASE SURE. ARM IN ARTS
ULTIMATELY WHAT WHAT I.
ONE EMPHASIZES WE'VE INVESTED
IN AND IN ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE YOUTH JUSTICE SYSTEM TO KEEP
KIDS LOCKED UP. WHAT THIS DOES
IT IS IT INVEST THE ALTERNATIVES
BY BY PUTTING MONEY IN THE HANDS
OF THE COMMUNITY?
PROVIDERS THAT ARE.
PROVEN EFFECTIVE AT PROVIDING
THE SERVICES IT BUILDS
COLLABORATION BETWEEN PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE ENTITIES THE COMMUNITY
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND ALSO I
IN TERMS OF COST EFFECTIVENESS
IF IT REQUIRES COUNTIES TO
PROVIDE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
MATCHING FUNDS.
TO UTILIZE EXISTING AND OFTEN
UNUSED FUNDS FOR HEALTH AND
DEVELOPMENT. AND AND AND AND
LASTLY IN TERMS OF INVESTMENT
FOR EVERYONE DOLLAR THAT WE
INVEST IN DIVERSION WE RETURN WE
GET THREE DOLLARS.
RETURN ON OUR INVESTMENT AND SO
YOU KNOW WE AT WHAT I CAN SAY IS
YOU KNOW THIS REDUCES HARM IT
INVESTMENT KIDS. AND IT AND IT
UTILIZES SCARES OFF WORKMAN
RESOURCES WERE NEEDS TO BE ALL
WHILE PROMOTING POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. AND
KEEPING OUR OUR OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE SO WE URGE YOUR AYE I'LL
AYE VOTE ON THIS THANK YOU. WE
WENT A LITTLE BIT OVER.
THAT IS WHAT THEY WILL. OUR NEXT
PERSON'S GONNA KEEP US ON TASK
GOOD.
I'M SHAME GOLDSMITH PRESIDENT
CEO LIBERTY HEALTH FOUNDATION.
CALIFORNIA HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
AND A RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT AND PROVEN COMMUNITY
DIVERSION PROGRAMS THAT GIVE OUR
YOUTH A SECOND CHANCE TO LEAD
SUCCESSFUL LIVES.
WE KNOW THAT SENDING KIDS A
PRISON DOES NOT WORK.
WE KNOW THAT AS MR GOODS MONTHS
THAT INCARCERATION LEAVES KIDS
WORSE OFF THAN IT FINDS THEM.
DETAILING A KID FOR A YEAR IN LA
COUNTY COSTS TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH THAT
SAME MONEY IF IT'S AND FIFTY
KIDS TO COMMUNITY DIVERSION
PROGRAMS THAT ARE THREE TIMES
MORE EFFECTIVE. AT PREVENTING
YOU FROM RE OFFENDING. I'M ALSO
A POLICE COMMISSIONER FOR THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT COPS
WHAT MORE OF THESE PROGRAMS THEY
TELL ME THEY ARE RESTING KIDS
THEY DON'T WANT TO ARREST.
BECAUSE THERE ISN'T ENOUGH MONEY
IN THESE COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
TO PROVIDE DIVERSION SERVICES
HAVE A COMMANDER FROM LAPD HERE
WHO CAN TELL I'M YOURS WHO CAN
TELL YOU HIMSELF. SO YOU CAN
CHANGE THAT YOU CAN STOP TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
BEING ARRESTED AND INCARCERATED
BECAUSE THESE ARE OUR KIDS THESE
ARE ALL OF OUR KIDS AND WE NEED
THEM. WE NEED THEM DESPERATELY
TO SURVIVE TO THRIVE TO SUCCEED
AND BY GIVING KIDS THE RIGHT
HELP BEFORE THEY STEP INSIDE OF
A JAIL CELL WE'RE GIVING THEM A
CHANCE. WE'RE SAYING THAT WE
BELIEVE IN THEIR POTENTIAL NOT
ONLY RETAINING THEIR LIVES WERE
MAKING ALL OF US SAFER BECAUSE
THERE WERE MUCH MUCH LESS LIKELY
TO COMMIT CRIMES THE FUTURE.
MY OWN BROTHER IF HE HAD HAD A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS TWENTY YEARS
AGO I AM CERTAIN THAT HE WOULD
NOT HAVE ENDED UP IN JAIL AND
HOMELESS FOR THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS.
IN PHILANTHROPY WE'RE PUTTING
OUR MONEY INTO YOU DIVERSION OF
THE HEAD OF A FOUNDATION I'M
PART OF A NETWORK OF FOUNDATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE. THEY'RE
INVESTING IN THESE DIVERSION
PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE SEE IT AS A
FIRST STEP AT ENDING MASS
INCARCERATION AND WE ALSO SEE IT
IS AN IMPORTANT INVESTMENT IN
FIXING THE RACIAL INJUSTICES IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. AS
THE NATION GRAPPLED WITH THESE
ISSUES.
THIS IT CALIFORNIA'S OPPORTUNITY
TO ONCE AGAIN LEAD WAS SOLUTIONS
THAT ARE GROUNDED IN SMART
POLICY FISCAL EFFICIENCY AND A
COMMITMENT TO JUSTICE
SO I URGE YOU TO PLEASE INVEST A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CREATION OF YOU THREE INVESTMENT
FUND.
THIS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M
HONORED AND HUMBLED TO SPEAK
WITH YOU BRIEFLY ABOUT THE
JUVENILE REST DIVERSION PROGRAM.
AND EXPRESSING ON BEHALF OF THE
ENTIRETY OF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND CHIEF
CHARLIE BECK IN PARTICULAR.
THAT WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF
FUNDING OF THE FUNDING REQUESTS
FOR THE YOUTH REINVESTMENT WHICH
IS BEING SPEARHEADED BY SIMPLY
MEMBER REGINALD JONES SAWYER.
I GREW UP IN THIS COMMUNITY
SACRAMENTO FAT AND OPPORTUNITY
TO GO DOWN TO. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PLAY FOOTBALL DOWN
THERE BUT THE COMMUNITY I GREW
UP IN.
IS DEL PASO HEIGHTS WITH THE
GRANT HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THAT COMMUNITY MAYORS WHERE
I WORK AT RIGHT NOW IS SOUTH
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES.
AND OF ALL THE COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED DIVERSION.
THAT COMMUNITY IS THE MOST
VULNERABLE.
AHMED IF THAT COMMUNITY DOESN'T
THRIVE THEN THE THE ENTIRETY OF
THE CITY OF LA DOESN'T THRIVE.
SO THE JUVENILE REST A DIVERSION
PROGRAM HAS BEEN A PRIORITY THE
LOSS IN LIKE THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT FOR THE PAST
FIVE YEARS.
BECAUSE OF THAT ORGANIZATION WE
INNATELY KNOW THAT A YOUNG
PERSON WITH A MINIMAL ADDRESS
HISTORY. OR WHO WAS BEING
ARRESTED FOR THE FIRST TIME.
HERE SHE MUST BE DIVERTED.
IT THE NUMBERS OR THE THEORY IS
TRUE. THAT A CHILD THAT IS A
RECIPE FOR THE FIRST TIME AS
OPPOSED TO BEING DIVERTED HAS AN
EIGHTY PERCENT CHANCE.
OF RE OFFENDING.
IN THAT SAME CHILD IF THEY'RE
DIVERTED.
WE SEE THE NUMBERS WHERE. THE RE
OFFENDING PERSON THIS GOES DOWN
ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT.
THEN CLEARLY IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S
ALMOST ILLOGICAL TO NOT DIVERT
IN OUR OPINION.
DIVERSE IMPROVISE THE YOUNG
PERSON.
AND HIS OR HER PARENTS OR
GUARDIAN AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN PROGRAMS OR
RECEIVE WRAPAROUND SERVICES.
THAT ARE GEARED TOWARD
ALTERNATIVES OTHER THAN
INCARCERATION.
WE FULLY SUPPORT DIVERSION FOR
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN THAT HAVE A
MINIMAL REST HISTORY.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR TIME
IN THIS MATTER AND WE URGE YOU
TO VOTE YES. AND RECEIVING A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. THANK
YOU.
YOU HAVE THE PUBLIC LEMLEY
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
.
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR JUST YOUR
NAME AND YOUR ASSOCIATION AND
THAT YOU'RE. A SUPPORTER NOT
SUPPORT.
IF YOU CAN. HOPEFULLY NO LONG
PRISON DO WE HAVE A MINUTE.
YEAH WE'LL HAVE A MINUTE OKAY.
IF NOT LET US ALL GO QUICK GO
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF AND CHAIR
IN THE. MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS JARED SIDE I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SENATOR
COUNCIL AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT OFFERS TRAUMA
INFORMED CULTURALLY RELEVANT
COMPASSION BASED TRAINING AND
PROGRAMMING FOR OVER SIXTY.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND SOME CALIFORNIA'S WELL AS
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ALSO TRAINS
INCARCERATED MEN WOMEN TO
FACILITATE THIS WORK IN TWENTY
TWO CB SI OUR PRISONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE'VE SEEN ENORMOUS
PROGRESS IN BUILDING CAPACITY
STRENGTHENING STAFF COHESION
ATTENUATING BURNOUT AND
ATTRITION AND CULTIVATING
RESILIENCE AMONG STAFF AND
SERVICE PROVIDERS WE TRAINED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SERVE YOU
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE
OVERWHELMED. AND THEY'RE UNDER
FUNDED AND THEY BENEFIT
ENORMOUSLY IMMENSELY FROM
INCREASED TRAINING AND RESOURCES
THESE FOLKS ARE EFFECTIVE
BECAUSE THEY'RE PROXIMATE TO THE
PROBLEM.
AS BRIAN STEVENS AS THEY ARE ALL
OF THE COMMUNITIES THEY ARE
EMBEDDED IN THE COMMUNITIES AND
THEY UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF
YOUTH IN WAYS THAT INSTITUTIONS
AND BUREAUCRACIES DO NOT AND
CANNOT.
IF PROPERLY RESOURCE
THEY REPRESENT A WAY NOT ONLY TO
KEEP YOU OUT OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM BUT THEY ALSO PROVIDES
THAT THE PROVIDE THE TYPE. OF
COMPASSION AND CONNECTION THAT
ARE CRITICAL INGREDIENTS IN
REACHING USE IN A RELEVANT A
MEANINGFUL WAY THIS YOU THREE
INVESTMENT FUND. IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERVENE
UPSTREAM WHERE THE VERY IMPACT
IS MOST EFFECTIVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
APPRECIATED.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROSA COMPARE WITH
POLICY MAKING THE ALLIANCE WITH
MEN OF COLOR IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON ROBIN THE PESKY CHIEF
PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL IN PARTICULAR THIS BUDGET
REQUEST IN PARTICULAR THE PART
THAT SUPPORTS PUBLIC DEFENDER.
SOCIAL WORKERS SOCIAL WORKERS IN
PUBLIC DEFENDERS OFFICES CAN DO
WORK WITH INTERVENTION WITH
YOUTH ADDED PARTICULARLY
CRITICAL TIME IN THEIR LIVES AND
IN A SPACE IN A PLACE WHERE NO
OTHER SOCIAL WORKER CAN HAVE
ACCESS AND TRUST.
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE TO THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE SOMETHING CUTE
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EMIR BROOKS MINTY A
UNITS ARE CONNECTIONS.
AND I'D LIKE TO APPROVE WILL.
GIVE YOU MY REASONS WHY YOU
SHOULD APPROVE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU GONNA O. HUNGER NO.
GO AHEAD OF.
AT THAT YOU PAUSES DOT OKAY.
OKAY BOSNIA COME.
I WANT TO LOOK TO.
WELL GOING NO MOST MY WIFE OWES
TRAUMATIZED UP THE TRUMPETS
PLAGUED US TRAUMA AND.
ARE YOU REALLY WANTED TO KILL MY.
BUT BECAUSE OF YOUTH MENTORING
CONNECTIONS WE SOLD MEAN
MULTIPLE WAYS SO COMMUTE MY
ANGER CAN YOU MY FRUSTRATIONS
COMMUTE MY ANXIETY AND.
THERE THERE THEY WERE THERE THE
WHOLE NINE YARDS
THEY WERE NOT BEEN THERE WOULD
NOT BE ME ON A SITE THAT WAS
ALWAYS THERE FOR ME SO FOOD HERE
YOU GO YOU YOU HOMELESS HERE
COME OVER HERE WE GO I GUESS WE
DON'T WORK WELL NO. WE DON'T DO
THIS WE WILL DO THAT AND I FEEL
LIKE.
THE FINAL GOING TO US MINUTES.
PROBLEMS THAT ARE GOING TO IN MY
LIFE AND I'M STILL STANDING.
BECAUSE OF YOUTH MENTORING JUST
THINK OF HOW MANY OTHER KIDS
WERE GOING TO.
FAR MORE SITUATIONS THAT ARE
WORKERS WHO DON'T HAVE
ORGANIZATION TO GO TO HOOTERS
HAPPENED SO KNOW.
MANY DISCO SUICIDE LET ME GO TO
MYSELF WHEN I GO TO IN THE
STREETS.
AND THEN WITH THAT REALLY PUTS A
TOLL ON YOU BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE
REALLY AT A LITTLE PLACE YOU'RE
REALLY AT A LITTLE PLACE.
KNOW YOUR MIND IS GOING TO GO
WITH THAT BECAUSE IT.
THE ABSOLUTELY SEE NO OTHER WAY
OUT.
AND I FEEL LIKE IF THIS FUNDING
FOR YOUTH MENTORING CONNECTIONS
WERE HERE. IT WAS SAME MULTIPLE
MULTIPLE LIVES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HATED.
MONEY MASSARI SOREL AMONG YOUR
FATHER THAT FAMILIES THAT
WALKING REPRESENTS STOCKTON SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY. ON INVESTING IN
INCARCERATION IS INVESTMENTS HOW
NEGLECT AND CHARM. THERE'S
ALWAYS A BACKSTORY OUR BABIES
HAVE TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES THAT
NEED TO BE A JUROR ADDRESS
CORRECTLY INCARCERATION ONLY
HELD TIGHT THIS TIME COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS HELPS HEAL
THIS TRAUMA WITH CULTURALLY RUDY.
HEALING PRACTICES ADVOCACY
MENTORSHIP AND LIFELONG
RELATIONSHIPS
AND CURRENT INCARCERATION IS
GREAT FOR PUNISHABLE HORRIBLE
FOR REHABILITATION.
HOW LONG ARE WE GOING TO SIT
HERE TWIDDLING OUR THUMBS AND
AND GOING TO THIS REVOLVING DOOR
IS TIME TO REINVEST OUR IT'S OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR YOUTH THANK
YOU?
ON.
AND INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTMENT IN ME WANTED GIVE US
YOUR NAME AND WELL MY NAME'S
DANNIELLA. THEN THE ALASKA AVAIL.
ON FROM STOCKTON CALIFORNIA.
AND.
I WAS IMPACTED BY THE SYSTEM I
WAS.
.
BUT IN THE SYSTEMATIC DETECTING
I.
.
I WAY EXPERIENCE BEING A PEPPER
SPRAY FOR THE FIRST TIME MY
EXPERIENCE BEING CYCLE FROM HEAD
TO TOE FOR THE FIRST TIME I
EXPERIENCED BEARD TWENTY FOUR
HOUR ROOM CONFINED FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
AND.
I WAS PUT INTO DIFFERENT.
GROUPON'S THREE DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS SINCE THE AGE OF
THIRTEEN I JUST GOT OFF
PROBATION. AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE FATHERS OF
FAMILIES WHICH I GO TO.
REALLY CHANGED MY LIFE. AYE THE.
BEEN IN THE SYSTEM HOURS HEAVILY
MEDICATED I WAS MEDICATED FROM
AM TO NOON TO NIGHT.
AND WHEN I WAS RELEASED I AGES
WENT CRAZY BECAUSE I KNOW HOW
THAT. AS WOULD OUR OWN ALERT I
WAS LEADING TO COPE WITH IN THE
SYSTEM AND. NOW THAT I'M A
FATHER FAMILIES AYE.
AYE HEAL NATURALLY.
I TAKE THERAPY AND I AM NOW.
.
ARMONK BECOMING A COMMUNITY
LEADER AND I THINK THAT YEAR
COME.
.
OF THE MONIES THAT.
WERE OPEN YOU GUYS INVEST IN.
IT PRO CONNECT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO EVERYBODY MY NAME'S THE
SENSUAL AND I'M WITH LAWS AND
FAMILY CELL CAN COME STOCKTON.
I'M A YOUNG FATHER NAM FORMERLY
INCARCERATED.
YOU KNOW THE SOCIETY SAYS I
SHOULD BE DEAD HAS BEEN IN MY
LIFE IN PRISON I'VE BEEN SHOT
TWICE.
AND.
AMMA IM OFFENDER WOULD STRIKE.
WHO WOULD COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE FATHER THE
FAMILY I'VE LEARNED TO HEAL
OTHER TO FORGIVE THOSE WHO HAVE
HER AN ARMY?
AND OF ASK AGAIN SO THE PEOPLE
WHO OPERATE IN HARM.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE CHAIN HOPE PROSPECTIVE LIFE.
I NEVER KNEW THERE WERE SO MANY
KIND PEOPLE LIKE.
PEOPLE AROUND ME BECAUSE ALL I
SEEN WAS HEY AS YOUNG. AS THE
YOUNGER YOUTH.
I WAS A RESILIENT AND I WAS A
VERY TROUBLED TEEN.
.
I DID SHOW NO RESPECT NOBODY.
ON MY INTEREST NOBODY.
NOW I SEE MYSELF OPENING DOORS
FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
TRY TO HELP THE YOUTH.
AND
LIKE HOW MY CHERI SAYS WHERE THE
POWER PROXIMITY ON THE WITH
THESE YOUTH ARE GOING THROUGH.
AND THEY UNDERSTAND US BECAUSE
WE UNDERSTAND THEIR PAIN AND
THEIR SUFFERING.
AND I JUST WANNA ASK YOU GUYS TO
APPROVE THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOV DO NOT TONY LERAY FOUNDED
YOUTH MENTORING CONNECTION.
AND I JUST WANT TO SPEAK REALLY
QUICKLY ABOUT PRE DIVERSION.
THERE ARE THREE GANG SETS
THAT YOU'VE NEVER HEARD OF IN
SOUTH CENTRAL LOS ANGELES
BECAUSE WE GOT TO THEM BEFORE
THEY TO DATA FOOTHOLD.
I CAN NAME ODD COUPLE A DOZEN
YOUTH WHO WE GOT TO BEFORE THEY
GOT ARRESTED.
SO WE DIDN'T NEED TO BE DIVERTED
WE FOUND THEM FIRST AND SOME OF
MY THICKER BEHIND ME TO SPEAK.
AND BECAUSE OF THE YOU KNOW
THAT THESE RESULTS WE HAD WE
DRAW YOU FROM COMMUNITIES TO
GRADUATE FIFTY PERCENT OR LESS
OF THE KIDS WE HAVE A NINETY
EIGHT PERCENT GRADUATE.
AND WE JUST SAW THE L. LA
COUNTY.
SAYS THAT THAT THE TEEN
PREGNANCY RATE IN OUR COMMUNITY
IS THIRTY TWO PERCENT.
OURS IS TWO PERCENT.
BECAUSE THESE RESULT OF HAD
THIRTY DIFFERENT COUNTRIES
COMMON STUDY OUR MODEL AND WERE
REPLICATED IN PERU AND IN
SINGAPORE.
WE WANT TO REPLICATE IN LOS
ANGELES.
WE NEED THESE FUNDS SO THAT WE
CAN DO MORE OF WHAT WE'RE
ALREADY DOING IN LA AND NOT HAVE
TO GO TO OTHER COUNTRIES TO SEE
OUR MODEL YOU KNOW BEING.
EXPANDED SO UP PLEASE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES THE BOARD
SHARES THE OBJECTIVE OF
DIVERTINGOUR YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THINKING
OF YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANGELINA SO
WHERE I'M A SOCIAL WORKER IN THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
THINK YOU I'M I JUST WANT TO YOU
HOPE I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS
THEIR HOPE THIS BOARD DOES
APPROVE THIS BUDGET ASK THANK
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALLEN MCDONNELL
REENTRY ATTORNEY CONTRA COSTA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS OFFICE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BUDGET ASK.
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL THAT OUR
CHILDREN IN A TIME OF CRISIS BE
CONNECTED WITH SOCIAL WORKERS
THE IDEAL WAY TO DO THAT IS PART
OF A HOLISTIC TEAM IN A PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE WHERE WE HAVE.
ACCESS AND TRUST AND WE CAN
CONNECT THESE CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES WITH THE RE ENTRY
SERVICES THEY NEED AT A TIME OF
CRISIS AND THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LESLIE CALDWELL
AND THE CHIEF OF PUBLIC DEFENDER
IN SOLANO COUNTY AND FOR ALL THE
REASONS THAT YOU'VE HEARD AND
ALL THE REASONS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR I. WANNA LEND MY
STRONG SUPPORT TO THIS BUDGET
ASK THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS GIOVANNI.
I'M AT RISK YOU TURN VOLUNTEER
AND I DO THE ICE WE URGE YOU TO
A PROCESS FOR NOT JUST THROUGH
THIS COMMITTEE BUT ALSO TO THE
REST OF THE HOUSES IN THE NEXT
LEVELS.
IT BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
SAVED MY LIFE. A LOT OF PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
GIVE YOU A SECOND CHANCE BUT
SOME OF US NEVER HAD A FIRST
CHANCE.
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
BARRIERS TO ENTRY FOR US TO GO
AND GET OUR EDUCATION SO WE
PLEASE STRONG YOU ARE SLEEPY
PROACTIVE. IN OUR DEVELOPMENT
AND NOT JUST REACTIVE WHEN WE
FAIL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
LEFT KNOW MY NAME IS JOE TO
BRIAN WOULD YOU JUSTICE
COALITION.
AMONG DIRECTLY SYSTEM IMPACTED
YOU I'M HERE TO SAY THAT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. NOT JUST FOR
ME BUT FOR MY LITTLE BROTHERS
MOTHER BECAUSE AND I HAVE THE
ONE THAT'S COMING UP I DON'T
WANT TO HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
SAME FAINTED AT THE SYSTEM
FAILED ME. ALL WANT NOW SYSTEM
TO FAIL THEM TOO SO.
A STRONG SUPPORT JUST ON BUDGET
THANK YOU.
OR GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ROAMING
THE BRIAN I'M HERE WHAT DO YOU
JUSTICE COALITION.
FROM THE SANDS OF THIS IN OUR
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LIVE PEOPLE.
WITH THE JUSTICE COALITION AND
I JUST WANNA SAY THAT ABOUT A
YEAR AGO.
ON. MY BEST FRIEND. ON NUMBER
THREE GOT LOCKED UP AND I COULD
ABOUT HIM I HAVE NO MANY.
HOME I GOT KICKED OUR MY HOME
WHERE THE GIRL LOVE.
I LOVE PLACES. BANK LOANS SISTER.
ED BUSINESSES TODAY HAVE EITHER
SPACE FOR ME I BECAME HOMELESS
ED WHEN I STEP ED I CAN'T TELL
YOU. HOW MANY TIMES I RAN INTO
AN OFFICER NUMEROUS OF TIMES
THAT I CAN'T EVEN COUNT ANYMORE
BUT NOT A THING ALL COMES THINK
MY NAME YOU KNOW? THAT APPROACH
TO ME AND WHEN I STEP INSIDE
CHIU BECAUSE.
AND SOMEBODY APPROACH SHOULD BE
IT SO BE. I HAVE OUR DATABASE IT.
IT I BROKE DOWN BECAUSE I'VE
NEVER HAD NOBODY TO TELL ME THAT.
THAT WITHOUT ME EVEN ONE IN THE
TOP THIRD LIKE PUBLIC QUE AT A
ONE TO TALK TO NOBODY THIS ISSUE
SAID I HOPE ALL THE DAYS.
AND EVERY REFILL SO GOOD IT NOT
ONLY THAT I CAME OUT WITH
LEARNING HOW TO DEAL HIM YOU
CIRCLES BUT I CAME OUT WITH A
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA. A CAME OUT
WITH BECOMING A LEADER FOR MY
COMMUNITY. AYE PARAMOUNT.
COME TO THE CAPITOL AND CHANGING
MY COMMUNITY BECAUSE CHANGES
RAIL.
I'M OF SOMEBODY TOLD ME YOU.
CALL TODAY SHE SAID IT REMINDS
ME A YOU.
IF I CAN REMEMBER EXACTLY HOW
SHE TO SAY ARE YOU. ARE EVERY
CHANGE IS LIGHT BEHIND
A DESK A OR WEIRD A A WE ARE I'M
A REALLY AMAZING DURING.
AND THE CHANGE IS NEVER. REALLY
CAUGHT AND REALITY. LIKE JUST
LIKE A DREAM IS NOT A REALITY
RIGHT BUT THIS IS WHY WE'RE ALL
HERE BECAUSE WE SEE THIS JURY IN
THE OLIVER'S.
AND MY STORY THIS ANY DIFFERENT
FROM EVERYBODY ELSE.
M. DIVERSION IS VERY VERY NEEDED.
AND EVERYBODY'S COMMUNITY NOT
JUST BECAUSE ONE COMMUNITY NEEDS
IT MORE THAN THE OTHER BUT
BECAUSE EVERYBODY NEEDS THAT.
I HAVE ALL DAY TO TALK TO YOU.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THING.
GOOD MORNING CAN GIVE ME A
JUSTICE COALITION WE WANT TO
URGE YOU ALSO TO PUT FORTH THIS
AS A NEW VISION FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY IN CALIFORNIA. ONE THAT
DOESN'T JUST DEFINE PUBLIC
SAFETY AS PUNISHMENT IN LOS
ANGELES WE SPENT THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS MORE YEAR TO
PROTECT STRAY DOGS THAT WE DID
PROTECT YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
VIOLENCE.
AND THAT'S AN EXCUSABLE AND WE
NEED THE STATE TO STEP IN AND
CHALLENGE ALL OUR COUNTIES TO DO
BETTER THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S KATRINA
RAISED AND I AM WITH AYE I'M
INTERNET WITH BY WITH THAT
WITHIN THE US EQUITY DEPARTMENT.
WITHIN DOT COHORT WE. PRACTICE.
CIRCLES ALL OF A LOT OF IT'S A
HEALING CIRCLE FOR ME AS A
TWENTY TWO YEAR COLLEGE STUDENT
I WAS I GENERATION PRODUCT OF
TEEN PREGNANCY I AM THE FIRST OF
MY FAMILY. OF MANY GENERATIONS
TO BREAK THAT TEEN PREGNANCY
CYCLE I'M ALSO THE FIRST IN MY
FAMILY TO GO TO A CSU OR EVEN A
JUNIOR COLLEGE. I'M CURRENTLY
WORKING ON MY VOUCHERS RIGHT NOW
SO I'M VERY PROUD OF THAT BUT
WITHIN.
THEY USE EQUITY DEPARTMENT IT
HAS ALLOWED ME TO REALLY.
ADDRESS MY TRAUMAS TRAUMAS DOT
SUPPRESSED ME WHAT'S KEPT ME
STUCK IN STAGNANT EVEN AT THE
CSU THAT I WAS OUT.
THROUGH THE HEALING CIRCLES I'VE
ACTUALLY. BEEN ABLE TO FORGIVE
FORGIVE MYSELF FOR FORGIVE MY
AND MY PARENTS.
.
TO START HEALING WITHIN MYSELF.
I WANNA START AND FOUND MY OWN
NONPROFIT BUT I REALIZE THAT.
BEFORE I CAN HELP ANYONE ELSE
OUT I HAVE TO HELP MYSELF OF THE
HUMAN START WITH ME THANK YOU
FOR DRUGS A PART OF THE.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MANY
IMAGE DOESN'T RODRIGUEZ I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF MYTH BODIES
SILLINESS.
COMING FROM A CITY THAT IS
MOSTLY ON YOUTH I SEE THOUGH
THAT MASS INCARCERATION IN GANG
OF OUR VIOLENCE AFFECTS OUR
COMMUNITY PERSONALLY HAVE
EXPERIENCES. FIRSTHAND WHEN I
LOST MY TWO CLOSEST FRIENDS AT
THE AGE OF SIXTEEN.
IT'S IMPORTANT OF US IN OUR NEXT
GENERATION APPROVAL THESE
HAILING INFORMED PRACTICES TO
HILL THE TRAUMA AND NOT JUST MY
COMMUNITY FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THAT. ARE AFFECTED BUT THAT
BEING SAID ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT
THIS REINVESTMENT THINKIN.
HI MY NAME IS DANA BRIAN I'M
HERE WAIT WHY JC YOU JUSTICE
COALITION.
AND I'M A RESIDENT OF SOUTH
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES I LITERALLY
LIVE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE GHETTO.
ALL I SEE A LOT A YOU SEE EVERY
DAY SOME YOU DON'T GO TO SCHOOL
I SEE OUR OWN OLDER FOLKS TO
WHAT IT ENDED THEY WON'T SERRANO.
LET YOU GUYS SEIZE THAT OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD IS IN A MESS.
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY WE ALL WE
DON'T HAVE ANYBODY TO TURN TO
NEARLY ALL INCARCERATED YOU
WON'T IS.
HAS BEEN TRAUMATIZE AND IS GOING
TO TRAUMA AND WHAT WE GET
INCARCERATED THAT REACH FROM A
THOUSAND US. THEIR NUMBERS ARE
THERE TO PROVE THAT ONE WEEK
WHEN WE GET LOCKED UP WHEN WE
COME BACK OUT WE KNOW BETTER
THAN HOW WE WAS BEFORE. WE HAVE
YOU WOULD SAID DON'T EVER
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL HOW VOTE
COUSIN.
THAT I MET LAST YEAR.
HE DIDN'T EVEN FINISH HIGH
SCHOOL WELL BY HIS EIGHTEENTH
BIRTHDAY HE WAS ARRESTED FOR NON
VIOLENT CRIME NOW UNKNOWN DRUG
CRIME. NOT EVEN JOB RELATED HE
WAS JUST SET A WRONG PLACE AT
THE WRONG TIME WITH THE WRONG
PERSON.
THAT PERSON GOT HIS FREEDOM BY
CHANCE BUT HE DID IT.
HE DID FOUR YEARS BY THE TIME HE
CAME OUT.
HE GOT A JOB THIS SUBTLE CAMERA
BLUE ON THE RIGHT PAT GOT TWO
YEARS PRO PROBATION A MONTH
BEFORE HIS PROBATION. AND TWO
WEEKS BEFORE HIS BIRTHDAY HE WAS
SHOT AND KILLED JUST BY A FEW
MEDIATION AND JUST BECAUSE
THAT'S THAT'S WHERE WE ARE WE
ARE WE GOING TO TURN WHAT WE
GOING TO TURN TO. EVERY BUT.
EVERYBODY I KNOW.
IS.
MOM OF A MAJORITY OF PEOPLE I
KNOW IS I DO OF.
ALREADY BEEN INCARCERATED GOING
TO THE SAME STUFF THAT I'M GOING
TO.
LIKE LIKE MY FELLOW FRIENDS SAID
EARLIER WE DON'T HAVE NO CLOSER
TO COME TO TALK TO US I'VE BEEN
ARRESTS ARE BEING. PULLED OVER
OVER A DOZEN TIMES.
YEAH I'M.
IT'S JUST ALLOW I'M SORRY BUT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANKFUL
THAT'S US WON'T COPPOLA REASONS
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVE I'M A
MEMBER OF THE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION.
EYES STARLING SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE I RECEIVED MY FIRST
PHONE ME WHEN I WAS EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLD. AND I WANT TO HELP
THOSE WHO ARE FORMALLY IN
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED IN THIS
MANNER OR SYSTEM THANK YOU.
MY NAME SPACE NIELSEN. AND THE
CHIEF PUBLIC DEFENDER OF YOLO
COUNTY A YOUR COUNTIES WILL
FORTUNATE BUT UNUSUAL BECAUSE WE
DO HAVE ONE JUVENILE SOCIAL
WORKER. ONE TO WORK WITH EVERY
CHILD THAT EVER COMES TO OUR
SYSTEM AND I CAN TELL YOU EVEN
THOUGH IT'S VERY SMALL PROGRAM
AND SHE IS ONLY ABLE TO HELP A
SMALL AMOUNT OF THOSE KIDS.
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THOSE
CHILDREN THAT SHE TOUCHES
THROUGH HER WORK HAVE BETTER
CASE OUTCOMES AND BETTER LIFE
OUTCOMES ONE HUNDRED PERCENT.
SO THROUGH THIS FUNDING HOPING
THAT WE CAN EXPAND THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY MONTEROSSO
CHIEF PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR ALL
DORADO COUNTY AND I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING
JUVENILES.
FROM CONTENT HIGH ALL THE WAY TO
SOUTH LAKE TAHOE.
AND THE ONE THING THAT IS TRUE
OF ALL OF THEM AND IT'S
REGARDLESS OF ZIP CODE IS THE
TRAUMA THAT THEY FACE AND THIS
IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT ASK.
AND I THINK YOU SIR FOR BRINGING
IT TO EVERYONE'S ATTENTION.
THANK YOU.
WE'VE GOT A LARGE NUMBER OF
FOLKS OUTSIDE WE MAY COME IN SO
I'M GONNA HAVE TO RESTRICT THE
COMMENTS OF A COMING TO. JUST
YOUR NAME WHERE YOU'RE FROM AND
THAT TOO IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
VERY BRIEFLY IF YOU HAVE THAT
THE SENTENCE SAYS WHY.
APPRECIATED.
I THINK WE'VE HEARD ALL THE GOOD
ISSUES THAT ARE HERE SO WE'LL
JUST MAKE SURE WE GET EVERYONE
ON RECORD FOR WHERE THEY'RE FROM
GOOD AFTERNOON NAP NAPA COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER RONALD ABERNATHY
THESE PROGRAMS WORK THEY IMPROVE
OUTCOMES WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THEM.
YOU FOLLOW AGREED INSTRUCTION
THANK CANNOT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MORE IN
WASHINGTON WITH THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND BECAUSE WE
KNOW DIVERSION WORKS IN SAN
FRANCISCO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL HARRIS
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE THE KIDS
COUNTIES THEY CURRENTLY DO NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES IN THE
COMMUNITY TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES. THAT ARE SO VITALLY
NEEDED IT WILL GIVE THEM A
CHANCE TO START. THANKS VERY
IMPORTANT THINK.
MLP SANDOVAL APPEAR MENTOR AT
VOICES NOMA.
AND I SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME'S EVERITT VECO FROM
VOICES ALSO OWNS A CINEMA AND
NAPA COUNTY NAY SPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE VOICES IS A COMMON FORM
CARE. CENTER AND THIS MONEY LIKE
THIS WOULD HELP US PROVIDE
COMMENT BEFORE CARE SPECIFIC
SERVICES THAT CAN HELP NOT ONLY
US HE'LL ARE YOU FEEL IN OUR
COMMUNITY HILL SO I THINK THIS
BILL ENERGY TO TOO. GREAT.
MY NAME'S LEMAR BANKS.
UP THEMSELVES AS WELL I AM HERE
YOUTH MENTOR AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL OR THE POSITIVE IMPACT
THEY CAN BRING UPON YOU. THANK
YOU.
MY NAME'S LAWS GONZALEZ SOME
WITH YOU SMOKE UP YOUTH
MENTORING AND I SUPPORT SPELL
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS QUEDAR ADMINS ARE
FROM SOUTH SIGH LA AND I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS YVONNE AND I'M
HERE WITH THE NEW EARTH AND I
STRONGLY A. AGREE WITH THIS.
THANK YOU.
I AM VERY GRAMMAR I'M WITH NORTH
ORGANIZATION LOS ANGELES I AM.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT HIS BILL
BECAUSE INCARCERATION BREAKS OUR
KIDS DOWN. IN THE TIME THAT WE
LOOK AT AND RE DESIGNED THE WAY
THAT WE. ALL DO THE SYSTEM AND
MAKE THE SYSTEM HAPPEN AND WORK
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M JANA SIMONE WITH NEW
EARTH ORGANIZATION FROM LOS
ANGELES SINCE WE STARTED
ORGANIZATION IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR WE WORKED WITH OVER TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE
MAINLY TOUCHED BY THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE OF THE
POWER WE SEE IN BEING ABLE TO
HAVE PROGRAMS LIKE OURS PRIOR TO
ENTERING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARCHAND GUITARS IN
THE PROGRAM MANAGER WITH NEW
EARTH AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME A CELL HERNANDEZ
SANTANA HEALTH POLICY ANALYST
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RURAL INDIAN
HEALTH BOARD REPRESENTING.
FIFTEEN HILFE INDIAN HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND FORTY FOUR TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU IN SOME
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
I'M SHARON OLIVER'S WITH THE
VALUE COUNSEL AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE ME
TYPES START TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY FOR YOUTH THANK
YOU.
HI I'M JANE LYMPHOMA CHARLIE THE
MASTER AT THE CALIFORNIA AND THE
MUSEUM CULTURAL CENTER AND ON
BEHALF OF THE ORGANIZATION I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BEN
MYERS I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
THE NATIONAL INDIAN JUSTICE
CENTER AND MY ORGANIZATION
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS HECTOR
PETTUS BUT JEKYLL WITH THE
NATIONAL PAUSE THAT WORK ON A
WE'RE STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
EFFORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BRENT
WOODS IN THE PUBLIC EVEN IF
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORTER SPILL SOCIAL
WORKERS PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE
WITH REGARD TO SERVICE THAT
PROVIDES A YOUTH. AND THEIR
ABSOLUTE NECESSARY REPUBLICANS
OFFICE
THANK YOU.
HI I'M LAUREL ARROYO I'M A
JUVENILE PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR
ALAMEDA COUNTY I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL I REALLY NEED
THE SOCIAL WORKER IN ORDER TO
HAVE EVERYBODY SEE THE. CHILD
NOT JUST HIS ACTIONS THINK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SASHA
ATKINS LAURIA I'M A SOCIAL
WORKER WITH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND LILY COLE BMI
FORMER FOSTER USE AN ATTORNEY
AND I'VE REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATES WE HAVE. OVER EIGHT%
THOUSAND VOLUNTEERS WORKING WITH
TWELVE THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI I'M GENEREX ROAD I'M A FOSTER
PARENT AND WITH CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CAREGIVERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANIEL MAILLET CALIFORNIA LINE
TO TOWN FAMILY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
BRENDA PARRY WITH THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI SUSAN ON FOX WITH HIS
DECISION CALIFORNIA CITIES
ALLIED WITH PUBLIC SAFETY IN
SUPPORT.
HI MICHELLE STILL PREVENT SKI
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS CALM WHO I I'M ON
THEIR ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
SOCIAL WORKERS ALSO OWN AN
ARDUOUS COORDINATOR FOR THE CITY
OF OAKLAND CALIFORNIA. AND WE
ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR.
TESTIMONY IS LOW COMMENTS
RESHAPE IT ALL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM ANY
MEMBER.
YES MISTER LACKEY.
YEAH I JUST HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION OF OF THIS.
.
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING IS BEING
ASKED FOR.
HOW MUCH OF THIS IS A FOCUSED ON?
PREVENTION.
HIGH RISK PREVENTION FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAVE.
I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
PROGRAM FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. KNOWN AS THE VITAL
INTERVENTION DIRECTIONAL OF
ALTERNATIVES VIDA PROGRAM.
WHICH I THINK IT'S. BEEN PROVEN
TO BE VERY VERY SUCCESSFUL.
OF.
IS THAT PART OF THE.
.
THE PROCESS HERE WE JUST TALKING
COMPLETELY OFFENDERS THROUGH A
DIVERSION PROGRAM SO NAM THE WAY
WE LOOK AT THIS PROGRAM ANY
ENTITY IN THE STATE CAN APPLY IT
WILL BE A GRANT FUNDED PROGRAM
TO DO.
THE SEC
AND SO IF A.
IF.
.
A COMMUNITY A CITY IT COUNTY
WANT TO APPLY THEY CAN APPLY.
BOB THE ONLY REQUIREMENT WILL
ASK IS IS THAT THEY HAVE TO PUT
ASIDE SOME MONIES TO HAVE SOME
SKIN IN THE GAME DILUTED DECIDED
THAT WANT TO BE INVOLVED. THE
PROGRAM YEAR YOU'RE MENTIONING
PROBABLY WOULD. WOULD DEFINITELY
QUALIFY BECAUSE THEY'RE ALREADY
EXPANDING.
FUNDING OF DEBT TO HELP AT RISK
YOUTH
AND SO THAT COULD BE ONE OF THE
ARM PROGRAMS THAT COULD APPLY
FOR FUNDING FROM JUST UNDER
MILLION DOLLARS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS JUST
STONE.
THANK YOU I'M HAPPY TO JOIN WITH
YOU ON THIS IN THIS IS ON THERE
A VERY VERY MUCH HOPE. THAT THIS
BODY WILL WILL PUT FORWARD IT'S
IT'S TRULY AN INVESTMENT. IN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN SHORT
CHANGED IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
FOR FAR TOO LONG WE WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT RACE.
ANYMORE IT'S NOT POLITICALLY
CORRECT.
WHICH IS A REAL SHAME AND IT
LEADS TO VERY DIRE CIRCUMSTANCES
IN SOME OF OUR MOST UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
WE SHOULD NOT BE SHOT THAT IF WE
GO IN I KNOW YOU'VE TOURED JUNE
OF FACILITIES AND THE JAILS. AND
IT'S MOSTLY YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
OF COLOR WHO ARE THERE BECAUSE
OF IMPLICIT BIAS AND SOMETIMES
EXPLICIT BY.
AND PUTTING MONEY.
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES WHERE
THERE'S FOR DIVERSION PROGRAMS
ARE PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND TO
ME A DIVERSION PROGRAM IS A
PREVENTION PROGRAM.
BECAUSE TAKING A CHILD WHO HAS
MADE A MISTAKE IN COMING FROM
VERY. DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES
THEIR OWN TRIBE IT'S THEIR OWN
TROUBLES IN THEIR FAMILY AND
GIVING THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ATONE FOR WHAT WENT WRONG BUT
REALLY. HELPING THEM.
UNDERSTAND THAT BE ABLE TO RE
INTEGRATE TO NOT TOUCH JUVENILE
HALL TO NOT TOUCH THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE KNOW EXACERBATE THE
RECIDIVISM RATES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. IS TO ME WHAT THIS
INVESTMENT IS ALL ABOUT AND WE
CAN EITHER CONTINUE SPEND
OBSCENE AMOUNTS OF MONEY
TO LOCK KIDS UP.
AND THEN LOCK THEM UP WHEN
THEY'RE IN ADULTS AND AND KEEP
THOSE CYCLES GOING OH WE CAN
START TO BREAK THE CYCLE.
AND INVEST IN OUR COMMUNITIES IN
A PRODUCTIVE WAY THAT ENSURES
THAT THEY WILLNOT SUFFER FOR
THE TRAUMAS THAT. THEY'VE BEEN
EXPERIENCING THIS WORLD NOT PASS
THOSE PROBLEMS ON TO THE NEXT
GENERATION SO THIS HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS I REALLY WOULD
HOPE WOULD BE A. DOWN PAYMENT AN
EARLY AND MICHELIN VESTMENTS
THAT WILL PAY DIVIDENDS AND WILL
KEEP US FROM HAVING TO EXPAND.
HUNDREDS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN THE FUTURE.
LOCKING PEOPLE UP BECAUSE THAT'S
BEEN THE PATTERN FOR TOO LONG.
AND THIS WAS.
THIS IS A GREAT PROGRAM I THINK
THAT THIS IS THE SEED FOR REALLY
SEEING HOW WE CAN SHIP. THE
JUSTICE CONVERSATION CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY FOR THESE KIDS
AND GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT SO THAT WHEN OTHERWISE BEEN
DENIED THEM SO.
I'M ENTIRELY WITH YOU ON THIS
THING SIR AND I HOPE THAT THIS
IS GOING TO BE A RECOMMENDATION
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND REALLY PUSH IT WITH THE
SENATE AND PUSH IT WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND SEE THIS IS AN
INVESTMENT SHOULD DEAL IN
ALIGNMENT WITH.
KINDS OF.
AND JUSTICE.
REALIGNMENT REFORM THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BEEN INTERESTED IN
AND THIS IS A LITTLE BIT OF PUT
YOUR MONEY WHERE YOUR MOUTH IS
THIS IS INSURING THAT WE'RE
GETTING TO THESE COMMUNITIES.
IN A WAY THAT WILL BE IMPACTFUL.
AND AND LEAD TO HEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES IN THE FEW.
YOU.
WELL I THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING
ARE WE APPRECIATE THEM.
THOSE WHO CAME SO FAR FROM OF
DOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
APPEAR TO BASICALLY EMPHASIZE
AND SUPPORT THIS CONCEPT. OF
THIS ITEM WILL BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION.
CLEARLY.
MOST OF US HAVE SPENT QUITE A
BIT OF TIME WORKING ON THESE
PARTICULAR ISSUES WITH REGARDS
TO BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR. AND
THE KINDS OF CHALLENGES THAT
THEY FACE AS WELL AS ALL OF THE
YOU FACE IN THE STATE.
I THINK MOST OF US WERE AGHAST
WHEN WE DISCOVERED THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY WE SPEND IN JUVENILE
JUSTICE.
PUT IN FIFTY TO THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR PER
CHILD UP TO A FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR PER CHILD. IT
IS STAGGERING WHEN ONE THINKS
ABOUT.
THAT LEVEL OF RESOURCES PUT INTO
ONE PLACE WITH THEM WITH THE
KIND OF SICK LACK OF SUCCESS
THAT WE HAVE IN THAT SYSTEM.
SO THIS IS UP HERE IN
COMPARISON TO THAT IT'S ALMOST A
DROP IN THE BUCKET REALLY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. A WHAT IT TAKES
TO KEEP FOR KIDS AND JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND COMPARISON TO THE
REQUESTS OF THAT'S THAT WOULD
LOOKING AT A MORE YOU KNOW SO
IT'S IT'S SO. IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
SEE.
WE CAN DO A MILLION DOLLARS OF
FOR ALL. FOUR KIDS AND STILL IN
IT WOULD LITTLE LITTLE SUCCESS
IN TERMS OF WHAT HAPPENED SO UP
WE WOULD EVER TAKE THIS ON A
SERIOUS ADVISEMENT THAT WE'VE.
.
I TALKED ABOUT IT WE WITHOUT
MISTER JONES SAWYER AND THOSE
WHO CAME.
BECAUSE SOME WHAT WE HAVE TO
TURN THE TIDE. AND AND DO WHAT'S
MARK. A RATHER THAN JUST
CONFLICT DO WHAT WE DID WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF. ALWAYS A
LOT OF FEAR MONGERING WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT NOT INCARCERATING
PEOPLE BECAUSE WE THINK
INCARCERATION MAKES PEOPLE SAFE.
BUT IT REALLY DOES NOT EVERY
COMMUNITY SUFFERS FROM T.
I GOT A CALL I GUESS THIS
MORNING LAST NIGHT WITH THREE
YOUNG MEN WERE KILLED IN MY
COMMUNITY MANDY AIGLE. ALL THEY
HAD BEEN GANG MEMBERS BEFORE
HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED ON AND
OFF DIFFERENT TIMES THAT'LL WHO
GOT OUT OF JAIL DIDN'T GET OUT
OF JAIL BUT IMMEDIATELY. KILLED
THREE YOUNG MEN.
AND.
AND AS A RESULT SOME OF THEM
FATHERS SO YOU TALKING ABOUT THE
TRAUMA OF THAT ON THEIR FAMILIES
THAT COMMUNITIES. THAT THE
CHILDREN THAT WILL BE COME WITH
THAT WILL EXIST IN THIS WORLD
WITHOUT A FATHER. WAS KILLED IN
GANG VIOLENCE AND ON AND ON AND
ON AND SO WE KNOW THAT THE
TRAUMA IS. JUST CONTINUES IS
INTERGENERATIONAL ARE AND WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY IN
WHICH WE STOP IT. OF CHILDREN
WHO ARE RAISED IN LIVING TRAUMA
A DO NOT IN THAT WOULD VERY GOOD
RESULTS WE KNOW THAT A WITH ITS
IN SCHOOL WHETHER IT'S AND YOU
WANT JUSTICE SYSTEM SO. OF%
CALIFORNIA'S BETTER THAN THAT I
BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY A WE KNOW
HOW TO DO THINGS WE JUST WRAPPED
UP THE COURAGE TO DO. YOU KNOW
AND THE RESOURCES SO THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH IT SOUNDS LIKE A
LOT OF MONEY. HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WAS JONES SAWYER HAS
BEEN BUGGING ME ABOUT. HOW MANY
YEARS ON THE?
I COULD PRY PAID FOR BY NOW.
WE COULD HAVE SAVED IT PASSED
THE BY NOW AFFINITIES LET ME SAY
THAT I I APPRECIATE ALL THOSE
WHO CAME THIS IS A SERIOUS
PROPOSAL. ONE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WILL LOOK AT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND I HOPE THAT THE
YELLOW THE MEMBERS AND OTHERS
WILL LOOK AT IT WE'VE HAD LOTS
OF ACTIVITY IN DISCUSSION AROUND.
OF THIS ISSUE AND WE'VE HAD LOTS
OF FOUNDATIONS THAT ENDOWMENT
AND OTHERS HAVE HELPED TO DO
SOME THINGS WE HAVE AMOUNT OF
RESEARCH.
AMOUNT OF RESEARCH ON WHAT IS
GOOD FOR FOR PEOPLE AND GOT AND
I THINK IS A STATE THAT HAS. HAS
SOMEHOW ANOTHER BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS THE STATE TO INCARCERATE MORE
PEOPLE THAN. ALL THE COUNTRIES
IN THE WORLD THAT'S CALIFORNIA
WITH ALL OF THE GREAT THINGS
THAT WE DO THIS IS A ONE SORE
SPOT THAT IS NOT A BRIGHT SPOT
FOR CALIFORNIA. A NONE OF US ARE
POLICE WITH ARC INCARCERATE
THEIR PRISON SYSTEM. ARE AND IT
AND WHETHER NOT IT'S AN
EFFECTIVE SYSTEM WE'VE BEEN
GRAPPLING WITH THAT. OF THE
OVERCROWDING THE TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY WE PUT INTO THE
OVER CROWDED SITUATION WE'RE
DOING OUR BEST TO TRY TO CHANGE
THE SYSTEM AND REFORM IT.
AND WE'VE REDUCED OUR PRISON
POPULATION WHICH IS GOOD BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO GET TO THE POINT
WHERE WE REALLY REDUCE BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT SENDING PEOPLE THERE.
AND THAT JUST LETTING PEOPLE OUT
EARLIER.
SO IT IT'S A MAJOR A MAJOR
UNDERTAKING AND I'M A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS STRUGGLE
VERY HARD TO KEEP THE DOORS OPEN.
THEY'RE PEOPLE WHO HIGHLY
COMMITTED.
TO MAKE IT WORK AND.
AND OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT WORKS
WITH THEM BUT THEY ALSO KNOW
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO IT SO.
I THINK ALL OF US HAVE TO DO
SOME SOUL SEARCHING WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR OUR KIDS.
SO THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
COMING THANKS OF ALL THOSE WHO
OUTSIDE FOR COMING AND THANK YOU
MISS JONES SAWYER FOR BRINGING
THE PROPOSAL FOR AND ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DEPUTY.
WE'VE HAD A REQUEST FROM MISTER
COOPER TO COME FORTY HAS A
PERSON WHO'S TRAVELED HERE WHO
HAS A FLIGHT TO CATCH I BELIEVE.
IS THAT RIGHT WAS LITTLE PER.
THANK YOU WE'RE GIVING EACH ONE
OF THE MEMBERS WE KNOW THIS WAS
AN EXCEPTIONAL ONE BECAUSE WE
HAD SO MANY FOLKS COMING FROM
ELSEWHERE. WE'RE GIVING EACH
MEMBER LIKE TEN MINUTES TO MAKE
THEIR PLEA.
SOME OF YOU'VE ALREADY BEEN IN
MY OFFICE ON YOUR KNEES AND SO
ON. I'VE HEARD SOME OF YOUR
PLEASE ALREADY. BUT DOUBLE ONE
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY MEMBER GETS
AN OPPORTUNITY WHOSE WHO MADE A
PROPOSAL TO DO THAT SO IT GOING
TO YOU AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO THE FIRST TWO ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA. OF THIS PROMISE
TO GO TO THOSE ITEMS THAT ARE
DISCUSSION ITEMS SO MISTER
COOPER THINKING NATURAL AND I
PROMISE TO BE DONE TEN MINUTES
IN OUR ASK IS MUCH MUCH LESS.
VICTORY OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU
SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
FUNDING FOR THE INTERNET CRIMES
AGAINST CHILDREN TASK FORCES OR
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS ICAC.
IN A CRIMES AGAINST CHILDREN
TASK FORCE PROGRAM THE NATIONAL
NETWORK.
SIXTY ONE COORDINATE TASK FORCES
REPRESENTING OVER THREE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
PROSECUTION AGENCIES.
THIS IS A CONTINUING GAYS IN
PROACTIVE AND REACTIVE
INVESTIGATION THE PROSECUTION'S
A PERSONS INVOLVED IN CHILD
ABUSE.
AN EXPORTATION INVOLVING THE
INTERNET.
CALIFORNIA OPERATES FIVE I CAC
TASK FORCES
LOCATED FRESNO SACRAMENTO SAN
DIEGO SAN JOSE AND LOS ANGELES.
HE'S LIFESAVING RESEARCH HAS OUR
FIRST ADDED TO THE STATE BUDGET
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
THE HEIGHT WITH A BEER BUDGET
CRISIS.
BY ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
SHORTFALL IN REVENUE.
THE LEGISLATURE UNDERSTOOD THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING
CHILDREN.
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION.
WELL FIVE MILLION IS A TINY
FRACTION OF THE ENTIRE STATE
BUDGET.
THE FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO THE I
CAC TASK FORCES.
I KEPT TASK FORCES ARE THE ONLY
ENTITIES FIGHTING. THE
FLOURISHING UNDERGROUND MARKET
IN CHILD* WHICH MAKES SEXUAL
COMMODITIES OF OUR CHILDREN.
EVERY WEEK CHOSEN A RESCUE
DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY BY AYE
TAX THE RICH THING SEXUAL
PREDATORS.
AS A FORMER COMMANDER THE SECOND
LIKE HECK TASK FORCE I THOUGHT
DIFFERENT LIES TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN FROM SEXUAL PREDATORS
ONLINE. NOW'S NOT THE TIME TO
GIVE THE FIGHT.
WITH YOUR DATE SUPPORT IS ALISON
ARNGRIM PRESIDENT.
THE BOARD OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION PROTECT CHILDREN.
MAINTENANCE KID ADAMS AND
DETECTIVE SHAWN SMITH
CONSECUTIVE VALLEY INTERNET
CRIMES AGAINST CHILDREN TASK
FORCE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
ALISON ARNGRIM ALL YOU MAY KNOW
ME FOR MY WORK ON LITTLE HOUSE
ON THE PRAIRIE.
BUT TODAY I AM HERE AS THE.
PRESIDENT OF NATIONAL
ESPECIALLY ILLEGAL.
WELL LOOK AT THE I WAS ACTUALLY HERE LAST YEAR
AGO WE WENT THROUGH THIS BECAUSE
I WAS ASKING FOR THE FUNDING TO
BE PUT BACK AND I'M. BACK IN
THOSE YOU WILL FROM THE LOWER
HOUSE WELL NOW NOW NO PROBLEM I
SEE VERY AGO AND I'M BACK AGAIN
AND AND WE WANT THE THE WORKER
OVER INTERNET CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN TASK FORCE TO BE
RETURNED TO THE BUDGET THEIR
MONEY. OF SEVERITY THE PROBLEM
OBVIOUSLY IS NOT A QUESTION WE
KNOW THAT INTO TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THERE WERE OVER EIGHTY
THOUSAND UNIQUE IP ADDRESSES IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH WERE TRADING
IMAGES OF CHILDREN BEING
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED. THESE
VICTIMS ARE EXTREMELY YOUNG OF
IN THESE VIDEOS WE'RE OFF THEIR
SEEING CHILDREN OFTEN LESS THAN
THREE YEARS OLD TODDLERS AND
INFANTS VIDEOS INCLUDE EXTREME
ACTS. OF VIOLENCE AND TORTURE
MOST OF THE VICTIMS IN THESE
CASES ARE NOT CAPABLE OF
REPORTING THESE CRIMES COMMITTED
AGAINST THE BECAUSE THE ICAC
TEAMS ARE ABLE TO FIND THE
VIDEOS THE PERPETRATORS IN THE
ACT. THEY'RE ABLE TO PRODUCE AND
NEARLY NINETY PERCENT CONVICTION
RATE.
WE THINK IS AN EXTREMELY
EFFICIENT COST EFFECTIVE METHOD
OF RESCUING THESE VICTIMS FOR
FURTHER RAPE AND TRAUMA. I
APPLAUD THE WORK OF THE BRAVE
MEN AND WOMEN FOR CALIFORNIA I
CAN'T TEAMS AND I ASK THAT THEY
BE GIVEN EVERY RESOURCE POSSIBLE
TO DO THEIR JOB. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SEAN SMITH WITH
THE SEGMENT ABOUT HIGH TECH
CRIMES TASK FORCE AND I AGAIN
FOUND HONOR TO COME BACK AND
SPEAK THIS YEAR THEY DID WITH
ALISON LAST YEAR.
.
AND TODAY I'M I'M SPEAKING AS
INVESTIGATOR NOT JUST
INVESTIGATE ABOUT A FATHER ALSO
ABOUT. RE THAT REFUNDING THE I
CAC PROGRAMS WHICH WITHOUT WOULD
TO ABSOLUTE DECIMATE THE ABILITY
FOR INVESTIGATORS TO GO AND.
COMMIT OR TO COMMIT THEMSELVES
TO THE SOLE MISSION WHICH IS
PROTECTING MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION IN OUR STATE TODAY
THE CHILDREN. I THOUSAND SAID
THE SPIKE IN THE NUMBER OF
OFFENDERS IS UNBELIEVABLE OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS. THAT
NATIONAL CENTER FOR MISSING AND
EXPLOITED CHILDREN THE TIPS IN
THIS TIPS OF CHILD* HAVE
SKYROCKETED FROM ONE MILLION TO
TEN MILLION PER YEAR WHO ARE
CURRENTLY ON A. TREND FOR ABOUT
A TWENTY PERCENT INCREASE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN ALL STATIC
FUNDING HAS REMAINED IN PLACE.
OUR TASK FORCE ALONE AVERAGES
ABOUT JUST UNDER TWO HUNDRED
CHILD* CASES WHICH ARE GIVEN
TO US PER YEAR EXCUSE ME PER
MONTH.
AND THESE IMAGES AND VIDEOS ARE
SOME OF THE MOST HAUNTING AND
HORRIFICALLY. UNBELIEVABLY
UNIMAGINABLE THINGS THAT YOU
COULD EVER.
HOPE NEVER TO SEE I SHOULD SAY
AND IT'S IMPORTANT NOTE THAT ARE
NOT CARTOON IMAGES ARE NOT
COMPUTER GRAPHIC IMAGES.
THEIR THEIR LIVING BREATHING
CHILDREN WHO WERE VIDEOTAPED A
DEFENSELESS BEING FORCED INTO
SEXUAL ACTS WITH ADULT MEN AND
WOMEN. TWO YEAR OLDS WHO ARE
BOUND AND HELD UPSIDE DOWN WALL
IN ADULT MAN FORCE HIMSELF UPON
HER. I'VE SEEN CHILDREN WHO ARE
HANDCUFFED TO TABLES WHILE THEY
ARE ASSAULTED BY DOGS.
I'VE SEEN CHILDREN DRUG FIXING
TRAINING VIDEOS OUT THERE
TODDLERS WHO ARE CRYING AND
BEGGING FOR THE ASSAULT TO STOP
INFANTS WHO ARE SHRINKING AND
SCREAMING IN PAIN.
THESE ARE BUT OF THE FEW OF THE
IMAGES THAT ARE BURNED IN MY
MEMORY FROM THE CASES I'VE
WORKED OVER THE YEARS.
AND WHAT'S MORE DISTURBING IS
IT'S FROM MANY CHILD PREDATORS
IT'S NOT ENOUGH JUST TO SIMPLY
VIEW THE VIDEO.
IT'S ESTIMATED IN OUR TASK FORCE
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS ABOUT
SIXTY TO SEVENTY PERCENT
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
INDIVIDUALS WE ARRESTED FOR
DOWNLOADING AND VIEWING CHOPPER
NOW GRIFFEY. WHO SUBSEQUENTLY
FOUND OUT AND THEY ADMITTED TO
EITHER HAVING GONE HANDS ON TO
ACTUALLY MOLESTED CHILD OR
PLANNING INTENDING TO DO SO?
AND EVEN MORE HORRIFIC TREND.
IT THAT THE VICTIMS ARE
SELECTING OR YOUNGER AND YOUNGER
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE REASON THAT
THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
DISCLOSE THE ACT COMMITTED UPON
THEM. THEY'RE TOO YOUNG TO TALK
FOR THEIR TOO YOUNG TO
COMMUNICATE EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED.
SO IN SHORT.
ARE AS ALISON SAID AS AS I.
EMPHASIZE THAT THE NUMBER OF
ONLINE PREDATORS OUT THERE IT'S
AN EPIDEMIC AND IT'S GROWING BY
THE MINUTE. AND WE URGE YOU TO
FIND CALIFORNIA'S I CAC TASK
FORCES WE DO NOT LEAVE OUR
CHILDREN DEFENCELESS THANK YOU.
SO IT IT'S AN CLOSING THINK
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO FOR THE
INTERNET YOU HAVE AN AFFINITY
FOR CHILDREN.
WHERE COULD YOU GO TO GET THAT?
THEY'RE THEY'RE NO VIDEOS LIST
MADE A HOMEMADE VIDEO BUT HE HAD
BEEN THE INTERNET.
CHOPPER DOT REFUSE TRADE ALL THE
TIME IN THE LAST FOR AXEL TREE
WILL SOON BE A PICTURE OF YOU
DOING EX Y. IN THE.
STILL THE TYPE IMAGES WE GET
WITH THAT.
CHILD* IT IS.
IT IS DETECTIVE SMITH SAID.
I NEVER THOUGHT THINGS LIKE THAT
HAPPEN TO I WENT TO THAT TASK
FORCE
IN IT'S IT'S IT'S RAMPANT OUT
THERE.
AND PEOPLE ARE VIEWING IT ALL
THE TIME IN DOWNLOADING IT AND
WITH THE BIGGEST ISSUE NOW IS
THE ACT UPON THAT.
NO THEY'RE THEY'RE GOING HANDS
OFF OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
AT IT AND IT'S THE UPLOADING
BECAUSE BILL IN ORDER TO JOIN
THE LITTLE GROUPS THEY WILL SAY
SHOW ME YOUR VIDEO.
AND SO THEY UPLOAD THEY MOLEST
THEIR OWN CHILDREN AND UPLIFT
VIDEOS.
DO HAVE ANY PUBLIC ANY COMMENTS
JUST TO NAME AND AGENCIES
SUPPORTER FOR WHATEVER.
CAPTION.
SHAWN HOFFMAN CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SHAWN HOP IN THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT THE FUNDING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH PRETTY GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT THAT
TAKES US BACK TO ITEM NUMBER ONE.
ON THE ITEMS TO BE HURT ISSUE
NUMBER ONE THAT HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM.
S. F. L.
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DEEMED BOARD
REPRESENTING THE.
FACILITY PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT DIVISION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
I'D LIKE TO START WITH A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM OR
THE HICKS THAT PROGRAM THAT
WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT TODAY.
I IT'S DESIGNED TO ADDRESS.
IMPROVEMENTS FOR PRIMARY AND
SPECIALTY CARE CLINICS.
AND OTHER RELATED OUTPATIENT
SERVICES THROUGHOUT OUR PRISON
SYSTEM.
IT'S BASED ON THE RECEIVER'S
TURNAROUND PLAN OF ACTION THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT AND THE IMPROVEMENT OF THE.
MEDICAL INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN
THE US DEPARTMENT IS ONE OF THE
COMPONENTS THAT'S NECESSARY.
TO RECEIVE. CONTROL OF MEDICAL
CARE BACK FROM THE RECEIVER.
IT'LL INVOLVE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND SQUARE FEET
OF NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
RENOVATION OF EXISTING SPACE.
TO LEARN THIRTY EIGHT SEPARATE
PROJECTS OR AN AVERAGE OF EIGHT
SEPARATE PROJECTS AT EACH PRISON
SO IT.
HAS THAT EFFECT FAIRLY.
FAIRLY HIGH LEVEL OF COMPLEXITY
TO IT.
WHAT WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED SO FAR
IS ABOUT TWENTY TWO PERCENT OF
TOTAL CONSTRUCTION STATEWIDE
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET OF NEW OR RENOVATED
SPACE SIXTEEN NEW BUILDINGS?
BETWEEN NOW AND THE END OF THE
CALENDAR YEAR WHERE IN A VERY
ROBUST PHASE OF CONSTRUCTION
WORRY ANTICIPATE GOING FROM
TWENTY TWO PERCENT TO SEVENTY
TWO PERCENT OF OVERALL
CONSTRUCTION. ANOTHER THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET.
THIRTY TWO ADDITIONAL CLINIC
BUILDINGS AND WITH ALL OF THAT
WE WILL HAVE COMPLETED
CONSTRUCTION AT SEVEN OF OUR
FACILITY STATEWIDE WITH THE
REMAINING FACILITIES TO BE
COMPLETED DIE IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
BUT AS HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED THE
PROGRAM HAS HAD.
COST INCREASES ARE FROM A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT.
FACTORS DESIGN ARAB ERRORS AND
OMISSIONS IN THE PROGRAM
UNANTICIPATED SITE CONDITIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD TO BE IT HAD TO
ADDRESS ONCE WE GOT INTO
RENOVATION.
AND A NEED TO CHANGE OUR
PHRASING PLANS A IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN MEDICAL OPERATIONS AND
SECURITY TO EACH PRISON.
IT'S LED TO SIGNIFICANT COSTING
CREATIONS GET INCREASES IN BOTH
HARD CONSTRUCTION DOLLARS
IDEATIONAL COSTS DUE TO GENERAL
CONTRACTORS BECAUSE THEY BID IN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS JOB THAT'S OUR
TWENTY FOUR MONTH JOB. IN THE
SAME THING WITH OUR.
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
CONSULTANTS.
IT FOR PROGRAMS FUNDED FROM A
VERY UNIQUE APPROPRIATION IN
TWENTY TWELVE.
BUDGET TRAILER BILL ESTABLISHED
A SINGLE APPROPRIATION TO FUND
ALL OF THESE THIRTY SOME ODD
PRIDE THREE THIRTY SOME ODD
PRISONS AND THE PUBLIC WORKS
BOARD THROUGH ACTIONS TO
ESTABLISH THE PROJECTS. AND TWO
OF FUND ANY AUGMENTATIONS
NECESSARY HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THAT APPROPRIATION AND
DISTRIBUTING IT TO THE DIFFERENT
PROJECTS.
HOWEVER THROUGH APRIL OF THIS
YEAR WE'VE REACHED ABOUT
EIGHTEEN AND A HALF PERCENT OF
THE ALLOWABLE TWENTY PERCENT
AUGMENTATION.
THAT'S WHAT BRINGS THE FINANCE
LETTER IN FRONT OF YOU HERE. IT
WOULD ADD SEVENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE EXISTING
APPROPRIATION FOR HICCUP.
AND THE AUTHORITY WOULD BE
ALLOCATED AND SORTED DOES NOT
COME TO THE DEPARTMENT ADDRESS
WITH THE A PUBLIC WORKS BOARD
AND WOULD THEN BE SUBSEQUENTLY
ALLOCATED TO THE DEPARTMENT ON A
PROJECT BY PROJECT BASIS. AS
NECESSARY.
EXACTLY FOLLOWING THE SAME
PROCESS AS THE EXISTING
APPROPRIATION HAS BEEN AUGMENTED
HAS BEEN.
UP ALLOCATED TO EACH PROJECT.
QUESTION ALSO ADDS.
NOTIFICATION LANGUAGE DUE TO
ITS UNUSUAL NATURE IN THE HIGH
PROFILE THIS REQUEST A
LEGISLATURE WAS HE REPORTS
WHENEVER THIS FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED THAT INDICATES HOW
MUCH OF THE SEVENTY THREE
MILLION HAS BEEN ALLOCATED. TO
WHAT PROJECT THE REASONS FOR
THAT ALLOCATION AND HOW MUCH OF
THE SEVENTY THREE MILLION IS
REMAINING.
WITHOUT A APPROVAL OF THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FOURTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN PROJECTS WOULD NEED TO
HALT CONSTRUCTION DURING THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR.
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO.
TO HELP PEOPLE OUT BY
PREDICTING WHEN THAT WOULD OCCUR
FOR EACH PROJECT AND WERE UNABLE
TO DO THAT BECAUSE THIS ISN'T
ABOUT CASH FLOW. IF THIS WAS
ABOUT THE PROJECTS NEED SO MUCH
CASH PER MONTH AND WE KNEW HOW
MUCH OF A HELP FOR THAT CASH
WOULD BILL WOULD BE ABLE TO
PREDICT. BUT THIS IS HAVING TO
DO WITH THE CHANGE ORDERS THAT
WE NEED TO EXECUTE WITH OUR
CONTRACTORS ON THESE PROJECTS
BECAUSE OF THESE CONDITIONS THAT
ARE ARE UNFORESEEN. SO EACH
CONTRACT EACH PROJECT HAS A
CONTRACT CONTINGENCY AMOUNT AND
WE CAN APPROVE CHANGE ORDERS
AGAINST THAT AMOUNT WHEN THAT
AMOUNT IS EXHAUSTED WE WILL NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO PROVE CHANGE
ORDERS IN THESE CHANGE ORDERS
ARE TO. ADDRESS NECESSARY
COMPONENTS OF THE PROJECT IT'S
NOT ABOUT A PERSON IS CHANGE
WHAT COLOR THEY WANT THE ROOM TO
BE OR WHAT TYPE OF DESK THEY
WANT THIS HAS TO DO WITH.
WALLS WERE SUPPOSED TO GO FROM
THE FLOOR ALL THE WAY TO THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE ROOF DECK THAT
ONE WE OPEN UP THE BUILDING FIND
OUT IT STOPS AT THE CEILING AND
SO WE'VE GOT TO CONSTRUCT THE A
FULL WALL. FELL THESE
UNANTICIPATED SITE CONDITIONS
REQUIRE THESE CHANGE ORDERS AND
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO HAVE THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND THEN GET
IT ALLOCATED THROUGH THE PUBLIC
WORKS BOARD. WILL HAVE TO STOP
FOURTEENTH EIGHTEEN PROJECTS IN
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
WE PROVIDED PROJECTED
AUGMENTATION AMOUNTS OF FOR EACH
PROJECT IN THE REASONS FOR THOSE
AUGMENTATIONS A TO THE COMMITTEE
AND TO THE LA OH.
UNDERSTAND THIS ITEM IS TO BE
ABLE HELD OPEN US WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
WEEKS TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THAT.
THE COMMITTEE AND OF THE OHIO
HAS.
AND THANK YOU AND I CAN ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE AT
THIS TIME OKAY AS THEY COME INTO
FINANCE.
HELLO.
JONATHAN PETERSON WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE SEVENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST FOR%
THE. INCREASE LEASE REVENUE
AUTHORITY FOR HICK THAT. WHILE
THE ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
SOME GENERAL INFORMATION ON HOW
THE REQUEST WAS DEVELOPED THERE
WASN'T A SUFFICIENT INFORMATION
TO FULLY JUSTIFIED THE PROPOSAL
SUCH AS. A THE SPECIFIC NEEDS
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED WITH
THIS FUNDING AT EACH FACILITY IN
THE COST OF ADDRESSING THOSE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OR HOW IT
ESTIMATED THE THIRTY POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN CONTINGENCY
FUNDING AND SPECIFICALLY HOW
THAT FUNDING WOULD BE USE.
IN ORDER FOR THE LEGIS THROUGH
WHAT IT THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE
THIS INFORMATION OR WHEN IT
CONSIDERS ANY.
FUTURE REQUEST RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTED
APARTMENT TO INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING INFORMATION ALONG WITH
ANY FUTURE REQUESTS THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING EACH PROJECT WOULD
RECEIVE HOW THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ON EACH PROJECT WILL BE
USED. THE INFORMATION JUSTIFYING
PROPOSE CONTINGENCY FUNDS HOW
MUCH ADDITIONAL OF LEASE REVENUE
AUTHORITY IS NEEDED TO PREVENT
PROJECTS FROM BEING DELAYED AND
WHAT PROJECTS WOULD BE DELAYED
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING. SO
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP THIS INFORMATION. ANY OF
THE COMMENTS REALLY WANT YOU TO
DEATH.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS IT
DIDN'T YES WITH A STONE JUST
WHAT I THINK ELIO MAKES A GOOD
POINT.
AND THAT THE INFORMATION IS FROM
WHAT I'VE SEEN IS IT'S FAIRLY
GENERAL AND FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
APPROVE THIS I WOULD HOPE WE
WOULD GET.
A MUCH BETTER STANDARD OF WHAT
WE'RE PROVING OTHERWISE IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE BEING ASKED FOR A POT
OF MONEY AND THEN BE TOLD WHAT
IT'S BEING SPENT ON. WITHOUT
KNOWING.
REALLY UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT IS
WE'RE GOING INTO AND SO I THINK
FOR OUR OBLIGATES OUR OVERSIGHT
OBLIGATION THE THINK IT WOULD BE.
REALLY BENEFICIAL TO TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS WE'RE
PROVING AND THEN OF COURSE.
GET REPORTS BACK ON HOW IT'S
BEING SPENT INTO IT SO WE CAN
ENSURE THAT SPEAK OF BEING SPAT.
IN THE WAYS THAT THAT WE WOULD
HAVE PREDICTED SO I THINK SINCE
IT DID DURING THE TIME IT IS
BEING HELD OPEN IF WE GET SOME
OF THAT INFORMATION. THAT
DETAILS WHAT THE EXPECTATION IS
WHY WE TO BE SPENDING MONEY
WHERE IT'S GOING TO BE.
EVERY PUBLIC AGENCY THAT I'VE
BEEN A PART OF WHEN THE GROUP
COMES BACK TO WHAT AND INTERNAL
PARTNER COMES BACK TO THE BOARD
OR COMMISSION WHATEVER IS MAKING
THOSE DECISIONS USUALLY WE HAVE
THAT INFORMATION.
BEFORE MAKING THE DECISION AND
THEN WE GET REPORTS AS ITS
TRACKING SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND EXPENDITURES THAT.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
WOULD HAVE ACCESS THAT
INFORMATION AS WELL.
ASSIST JONES SAWYER.
I GUESS IS THE SECOND.
WEEK THAT I'VE BEEN HERE.
AND BUT THEN OUT NUMBER FIRST
TIME WITH WITH WITH THE COURTS
AND AND I'M.
SCOTT PERPLEXING TO ME ID LIKE.
I NEED TO FIND OUT WHO THE HELL
DOES YOUR COST ESTIMATES BECAUSE
IT DIDN'T SEEM LIKE ANYBODY COME
IN ON TIME AND IF ANYBODY NEEDS
TO BE FIRED IS THAT GROUP OR
NEVER USE THEM AGAIN BECAUSE.
SEEM LIKE DIFFERENCES BOTTOMLESS
PIT.
OF COMING BACK AND ASKING FOR
MORE MONEY WHEN YOU GUARANTEE OR
YOU SAY WE'RE GOING TO FINISH
THIS HOUSE.
AND.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND THEN BROUGHT
THE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND STILL
ASKING FOR MORE MONEY.
STILL WHILE LISTING OF EVER SEEN
AND I'VE BUILT.
A COUPLE OF.
CITY SHACKS IN MY DAY. SO.
.
I'M I'M WITH.
MR STONE AND AND OTHERS ABOUT
COMING BACK ABOUT COMING TO WORK
TO LET US KNOW ON YOUR BEST
ESTIMATE AND HOPEFULLY YOU DON'T
USE THE SAME PEOPLE THEY GAVE
YOU ORIGINAL ESTIMATE. BUT YOUR
BEST ESTIMATES ON HOW YOU CAN
BRING THIS TO A CLOSE AND HOW
YOU CAN GET SOMETHING BUILT AND
DONE. SO THAT I AM.
IT'S MORE THAN OVERSIGHT IT'S
IT'S LIKE COME.
LIKE HAVING RESPONSIBILITY TO
FINISH SOMETHING.
IF YOU LIKE THE STATE.
CAN'T QUITE GET THAT IS NOT MUCH.
DOING YOU LIKE YOUR FRUSTRATION
I HAVE WITH
COURTS AND SOME OTHERS.
SO UP I THINK WILL BE VERY VERY
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THIS
COMMITTEE.
TAKE TO COME BACK WITH A AN
OVERALL PLAN.
ON HOW MUCH MORE MONEY YOU NEED
WHAT YOU CAN AND CAN'T DO WITH
THE MONEY YOU HAVE AND SO THAT
WE CAN NAM.
WE CAN MAKE THE BEST.
DECISION THE BEST EDUCATED
DECISION WITH TAXPAYER MONEY.
INSTEAD OF.
BUT I DON'T BE HERE I'M HERE FOR
ANOTHER SIX YEARS I DON'T BE.
THREE YEARS TALKING ABOUT THIS
AGAIN.
THE DOCTOR WEBER SOLA HOPEFULLY
WEAKEN NAM. YOU GET SOME ANSWERS
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
LET ME LET ME SEE IF I I I I IF
I UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON.
THIS ISN'T IT EVERY QUEST WOULD
DISH NO DOLLARS.
AND THEN YOU. PUT IT OUT TO BID
AND THEN YOU FIGURE OUT WHAT
IT'S GOING TO PAY FOR AND.
DOES SOUND LIKE.
THAT'S WHAT AND THEN WE FIND OUT
HOW IT SPENT IS THAT.
WHAT NORMALLY HAPPENS LIFT YOUR
VISION OF WHAT OUGHT TO HAPPEN
BUT I DIDN'T KNOW MEN TARA LET
ME TRY TO EXPLAIN AS SIMPLY THE?
PUBLIC WORKS. WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT IDENTIFIES THAT
THERE'S A COST TO INCREASE AND A
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING ON
THE SIX FOOT PROJECTS WE HAVE TO
PREPARE A REQUEST TO THE STATE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD THAT
IDENTIFIES.
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE WHAT'S
CAUSING THE NEEDS ARE HOW THAT
IMPACTS SCHEDULE AND ALL THE
ABOVE AND THEN THE?
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD WOULD A
REVIEW THAT ACTION AND AND
EITHER PROVE OR ASK QUESTIONS OR
WHATEVER.
THEY'RE THEY'RE.
ACTION ON IT ON IT WOULD BE SO
THESE PROJECTS ARE ALREADY
ALREADY OUT TO BID RA AND
THEY'RE UNDER UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
SO BECAUSE THE BIDS WERE BASED
UPON THE PLANS AS THE PLANS
ESTABLISHED AT AT THE TIME OF
BIDDING WHAT WE'VE FOUND IS THAT
THESE PLANS OF HAD TO BE
ADJUSTED BECAUSE OF POOR ACT
IMPORT DUTIES BY THE ANY FIRMS
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
OR BECAUSE WE AND WE START
RENOVATION AND AND THIS WHAT
MAKES THIS PROJECT ESPECIALLY
COMPLICATED IS THAT SOMETIMES
WE'RE BUILDING BRAND NEW
BUILDINGS ALL THE TIME FOR GOING
INTO EXISTING BUILDINGS
RENOVATING ADDING ON TO THOSE
BUILDINGS. AND THAT'S WHEN WE
FIND OUT THAT ONE THAT BUILDING
WAS BUILT FIFTEEN YEARS AGO EVEN
THOUGH THE PLAN SAY ALL THESE
ITEMS WERE BUILT TO CODE. WE
OPEN UP THE WALL AND YOU FIND
IT'S NOT THERE AND HOW THE FIRE
MARSHAL IN THE CONTRACTOR THAT
TIME GOT THE BUILDING SIGNED OFF.
I HAVE NO IDEA BUT THAT'S WHAT
THE FIRE MARSHAL NOW HOLDS US TO
TO REPAIR THAT SO IT'S NOT THAT
WE ARE CHANGING THESE PROJECTS
AS WE GO ALONG. IT'S THAT WE
FIND THESE UNANTICIPATED
CONSEQUENCES AND HAVE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
CONTRACTOR TO WELL FIRST WE HAVE
TO WORK WHETHER ANY FIRM TO
DESIGN WHAT'S NECESSARY TO THAT
HAVE THE CONTRACTOR.
PRICE IT OUT IN NEGOTIATE WITH
CONTRACTOR TO GET THAT
ADDITIONAL WORK DONE. AND ALL
THAT'S GOING TO BE NECESSARY
BEFORE WE CAN HAVE A FIRE
MARSHAL COME IN AND SAY YES THIS
BUILDING IS READY FOR OCCUPANCY.
SO THAT'S THE PHASE OF THESE
PROJECTS THAT WERE IN THERE ARE
AS A CONTRACTOR THERE AND WE ARE
TRYING TO MANAGE AND MINIMIZE
THESE. IMPACTS BUT WE AS THE
EIGHTEEN AND A HALF PERCENT OF
AUGMENTATION ALREADY IDENTIFIES
THAT'S THE PROJECT WE'VE HAD
IDENTIFIED TO GET TO THIS POINT.
WE'VE IDENTIFIED ABOUT FOURTEEN
OR THE PROJECTS THAT WE KNOW
WILL NEED FUNDING AUGMENTATION
SOMETIME IN THE NEXT SIX MONTHS.
AND THAT'S PRIMARILY WHAT THIS
MONEY IS FOR THAT WE WOULD BE
GOING THROUGH THE PUBLIC WORKS
BOARD TO GET THOSE AUGMENTATIONS
APPROVED.
A NOTE ON THE CONTINGENCY THE
REASON WHY THERE IS CONTINGENCY
BUILT IN THE SEVENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IS BECAUSE OUR
INFORMATION FOR HOW MUCH MONEY
WE NEED. IS ONLY AS GOOD AS
EVERYTHING WE KNOW AT THE TIME
THAT WE PUT THESE ESTIMATES
TOGETHER SO BACK IN FEBRUARY
WHEN WE DEVELOP THESE ESTIMATES.
THE PHASE OF CONSTRUCTION WE ARE
IN ALLOWED US TO KNOW WHAT OUR
PROBLEMS WERE BUT IF THIS IS A
BUILDING THAT HAS THREE OR FOUR
MORE PHASES RENOVATION THAT WE
HAVE AN OPEN THE WALLS ON YET.
WE CAN ANTICIPATE THAT
UNFORTUNATELY THERE MAY BE
ADDITIONAL CHANGES. AND IF WE
DIDN'T PUT MONEY FORWARD INTO
THE PROJECT A INTO THIS REQUEST
AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
WE WOULD FIND THAT THE MONEY WE
ASK FOR WOULDN'T BE SUFFICIENT
TO GET US TO THE END. ANSWER WE
MAY STILL FACE SITUATION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
APPROVED A THIRTY OR FORTY
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE ANY OF
THE PROJECT MAY STILL HAVE TO A
HALT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE FISCAL
YEAR INTEL A FURTHER INCREASE
COULD COME THROUGH. THIS IS OUR
EFFORTS TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
PUT MONEY ASIDE FOR THE UNKNOWNS
WHICH IF THE ANNOUNCEMENT
MATERIALIZE NEVER GETS
APPROPRIATED BY THAT NEVER GETS
ALLOCATED BY THE PUBLIC WORKS
FOR TO US. AND STAYS IN THE
APPROPRIATION BUT WE.
AND MISTER JONES SAWYER MENTION
WE DON'T WANT TO BE HERE AGAIN
NEXT YEAR OR THREE YEARS FROM
NOW ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL MONEY
FOR THIS AND THIS WAS OUR BEST
EFFORT TO PUT TOGETHER. THE
AUGMENTATION WE FEEL IT'S
NECESSARY TO COMPLETE THESE
PROJECTS.
IS IT POSSIBLE YOU CAN GIVE US
THE UP.
BOTH FOR THE MEMBERS THAT.
PROJECT BY PROJECT
IDENTIFICATION OF OF. THE AMOUNT
THAT'S GOING TO BE SPENT AND WHY.
INCREASED.
WHICH I POSSESS THAT SHOOT SOME
IT'S AVAILABLE A CREAM ON
ROBERT'S APARTMENT FINANCE IT'S
ACTUALLY WORKSHEETS WITHIN THE
FINANCE LETTER SO.
FOURTEEN OF THE PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED THAT WE CAN GIVE YOU
IS ANOTHER COPY OF THAT IT'S
HELP YEAH THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
YEAH AND ALSO IF I COULD JUST
ADD REALLY QUICKLY THE M. SCOPE
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ON
THE SAME PAGE THE SCOPE IS
CONSISTENT WITH ALL TWENTY FIVE
PROJECTS THAT WERE ESTABLISHED
IN THE STATE PUBLIC WORKS BOARD
WHERE AND THE SCOPE IS ALSO
CONSISTENT WITH THE FUNDS. THAT
WERE APPROPRIATE THROUGH BOTH AB
NINE HUNDRED AND SENATE BILL TEN
TWENTY TWO THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE.
FOR THE HECK OF IT PROGRAM
RIGHT ANY OF YOU ORIGINALLY
GIVEN WHAT NINE HUNDRED MILLION.
THE AND YOU'VE SPENT SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION APPROXIMATELY AT
THIS POINT.
YOU SPENT ALL. THAT WELL IT'S
COMMITTED AYE I DON'T IT'S NOT
REALLY ON A CASH BASIS PER SE
BUT YES THE NINE HUNDRED MILLION
IS FULLY COMMITTED PLUS ANOTHER
HUNDRED AND FORTY SOMETHING. IN
AUGMENTATIONS WHATEVER THE
AMOUNT THAT WE ARE GONNA WAS
NINE HUNDRED YES WE'VE DONE THE
ONE SIXTY SEVEN AUGMENTATION YES.
AND NOW WE NEED SEVENTY OR
EIGHTY SEVEN MORE BUT WHAT
SEVENTY THREE MORE AND THEN
THERE'S THE AUGMENTATION
AUTHORITY ATTACHED THAT SEVENTY
THREE IF IF NECESSARY.
SO IN THE END WHAT'S THE TOTAL.
BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE ONLY REQUEST
IN SEVENTY THREE MILLION WE'RE
NOT ASKING TO DIP INTO THE
ADDITIONAL IT CAN GET TO EIGHTY
SEVEN WE'VE ALREADY DONE THE ONE
SIXTY SEVEN. CRACKED AND WE
ALWAYS IN THE NINE HUNDRED WHICH
IS IT'S ONE POINT ONE BILLION
ONE.
SO WE SPENT ONE POINT SIX
BILLION THOSE ARE ONE POINT SIX
BILLION RIGHT NOW. M..
NO NO ONE POINT ONE BILLION FOUR
ONE ONE ONE POINT OH FOR IS WHAT
THE ONE THE.
.
NINE HUNDRED MILLION NINE
HUNDRED MILLION THE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN PLUS THE ADDITIONAL
SEVENTY THREE REQUESTING WOULD
YOU HAVE TO ONE BILLION FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
ALRIGHT I WISH I WAS IN THAT
QUICK MATHEUS. OKAY TAKES A
BREATH WAY YEAH YEAH I KNOW IT'S
AMAZING.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
LOT OF MONEY ALRIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BRINGS TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO.
WHICH IS.
YES AND THAT THAT ITEM WILL BE
HELD OPEN.
WELL YES EARLY EARTHQUAKE
WARNING SYSTEM BUSINESS PLAN.
OKAY GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL HERE
JUST WANT TO SAY A COUPLE THINGS
THAT THAT ARE IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE BEGIN.
.
WE JUST RECEIVED RELEASE IDEA
THIS FINAL BUSINESS PLAN ABOUT
FIVE DAYS AGO.
I AND WHICH DOES NOT INTO LARGE
PLAN DOESN'T GIVE US MUCH TIME
TO DIGEST ALL THAT'S IN IT.
AN EARLY EARTH QUAKE WARNING
SYSTEM CAN REDUCE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF HARM TO PEOPLE IN
INDUSTRIES WHEN I CATASTROPHIC
EARTHQUAKE HITS.
SO WE DEFINITE ONE HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE SYSTEM UP AND RUNNING.
TO PROVIDE AS MUCH NOTICE AS
POSSIBLE TO PEOPLE BECAUSE WE
KEEP HEARING THE BIG ONE IS
COMING.
BUT IF THE DEVELOPMENT AND ROLL
OUT IS NOT DONE CORRECTLY. I
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EFFECT OF A SET OF SUCH A SYSTEM
THAT DOESN'T HAVE THE CONFIDENCE
OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. UNDERSTAND THAT
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE BUT I HAD
A GOOD BUDDY HASTY ROLLOUT
DOESN'T MINIMIZE FALSE ALARMS.
FIGURE OUT SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
AND ADEQUATELY. ABOUT INFORMED
PEOPLE HOW THE SYSTEM SHOULD BE
USED A WE WILL HAVE MORE
PROBLEMS THAN SOLUTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL LIABILITIES THAT
MAY RESULT FROM A FALSE ALARM.
THE WARNING GOES OUT A DOCTOR
AND HOSPITAL STAFFS MEET SURGERY
THE WARNING IN THE BEEN FALSE
BUT MAYBE THAT SHORT DELAY HARMS
THAT PATIENT ON THE TABLE.
WHO BEARS WHAT RESPONSIBILITY IS
AT THE HOSPITAL OR THE STATE?
OR FALSE ALARM HAPPENS AND
PEOPLE RUN OUT INTO THE STREETS
AND CHAOS ENSUES.
FOR THIS SUBCOMMITTEE TO WEIGH
IN ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT PROJECT
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE IT IS DONE
RIGHT. MINIMIZE AREAS TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND HOW TO
USE IT WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A WAY TO PAY FOR IT.
YOU'VE GIVEN US VARIOUS OPTIONS
TO PAY FOR IT BUT.
.
AND THOSE.
NO REAL RECOMMENDATIONS
THE BUSINESS PLAN ANSWER SOME
QUESTION BELIEVES OTHERS OPEN
WHEN IT IS CONCERNED WHICH IS
MOST CONCERN TO ME. FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S A TABLE POSSIBLE FUNDING
SOURCES WOULD NOT A REAL DEAL OF
ANALYSIS GREAT DEAL OF ANALYSIS.
I'M EXPECTING THERE IS TO BE
MORE INFORMATION AND
RECOMMENDATIONS WE WAS EXPERTS
OF WHAT IS THE MOST FEASIBLE I'M
EXPECTING YOUR PRESENTATION
TODAY TO ANSWER THESE CRITICAL
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE
CONCERNING THIS EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM.
OKAY OKAY THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US PACK AND.
AS YOU INTRODUCED I'M HERE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE RYAN ARBROATH WAS
ALSO WITH CALLAWAY ES IN THE
EARTHQUAKE PROGRAM. THE KIND OF
BREAKDOWN THE BUSINESS PLAN WHAT
IT INCLUDES IT IS A LARGE
DOCUMENT WE REALIZE THERE ARE
THE BEEN A LOT OF TIME TO TAKE
IT ALL IN. AND THEN HOPEFULLY
I'M ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS AT
LEAST HELP US FOR THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT SYSTEM AND AND HOW WE
PLAN TO. TO ROLL OUT IN CARRY
FORWARD SO FIRST OF ALL THAT
BUSINESS PLAN REALLY PAN COMES
DOWN TO FOUR BASIC COMPONENTS IN
THIS WAS DIRECTED FOR US TO
CREEK TO CREATE BY STATUTE. OF
ABOUT A YEAR OR SO AGO AND
MANDATED WHAT IT SHOULDN'T.
CLUED IN THAT IS ESTIMATES FOR
WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO
FINISH BUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS
THIS WARNING SYSTEM. AS WELL AS
WHAT THE RECURRING COSTS ARE
EXPECTED TO BE THAT CONTAINS IT
IT WAS TO IT AT DIRECTED US TO.
IDENTIFY SOME FUNDING OPTIONS
FOR FORUM HOW WEEKS HOW WE PLAN
TO CARRY OUT THE FUTURE. IT
ASKED US TO LAY OUT A PLAN FOR
HOW TO BE ROLLED OUT TO THE
PUBLIC AND THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND THEN FINALLY IDENTIFY RISKS
AND BENEFITS OF THOSE OF THE
BASIC COMPONENTS OF IT.
I THINK THAT.
THE FUNDING.
ESTIMATES FOR THE BILL DOWD AND
THE RECURRING COSTS HOPEFULLY
THAT SORT OF SPEAKS FOR ITSELF
BUT IT BREAKS IT DOWN BY
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS PART OF
THAT INCLUDES WHAT WE'VE. WE'VE
ASKED FOR IN THE IN THE BUDGET
REQUEST FOR FIFTEEN POINT SEVEN
FIVE MILLION WHICH IS TO
COMPLETE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILD OUT FOR THE SEISMIC
SENSORS THAT DETECT THE
EARTHQUAKE. AND AND.
INITIATE THAT EARLY ALERT TO.
TO THE PUBLIC INTO CALIFORNIANS.
IT ALSO CONTAINS IS YOU HAVE.
AS YOU'VE NOTED THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF WAYS THAT IT COULD BE
FUNDED ENOUGH IT'S OKAY I'LL GET
BACK TO THAT. AND.
IT TALKS ABOUT A TIME LINE FOR
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN WHEN FROM
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND GOING
FORWARD TO ROLL OUT THE SYSTEM
FOR REAL USE. AND THEN.
THE VARIOUS RISKS AND BENEFITS
OF AND THE PLAN KIND OF TAKING
OUT ALL AND RECOMMENDS THAT
CALLAWAY YES DO A FEW THINGS
FIRST IT RECOMMENDS THAT WE.
NEGOTIATE A FORMAL AGREEMENT
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT USE
ANOTHER BIG PARTNER AND
DEVELOPING THIS SYSTEM HAS BEEN
FOR MANY YEARS.
IT TALKS ABOUT US FINALIZING
WHAT'S CALLED A TELEMETRY PLAN
WHICH IS.
A TECHNICAL TECHNICAL TERM FOR.
HOW THE SENSORS IN THE GROUND
SPEAK TO?
YOU KNOW TALK TO THE
INFORMATION NETWORKING GET THE
ALERT OUT TO PEOPLE AND.
IT IT TELLS US TO ACCESS TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
DIFFERENT FUNDING OPTIONS AND SO
WERE ALREADY WORKING ON THOSE
THINGS WERE NOT.
WAITING NOW THAT THE BUSINESS
PLAN IS OUT.
WERE PROCEEDING AND I CAN SAY
THAT WITH OUR PARTNERS IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE UNITED
STATES GEOLOGICAL SURVEY WE'VE
ALREADY DEVELOPED A A DRAFT
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING THE
TWO AGENCIES ARE WORKING THROUGH
THAT RIGHT NOW.
FORTUNATELY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RECENTLY ALSO
ALLOCATE IT'S MORE FUNDS THAT
WILL HELP US BUILD THIS OUT IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S TALKED ABOUT
IN THE PLAN.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF.
THINGS ARE COMING TOGETHER AND
BOTH ENTITIES ARE VERY MOTIVATED
TO MOVE FORWARD FORWARD QUICKLY
BUT CAREFULLY AND WHICH IS WHY
ON OUR ROLL OUT PLAN FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND BEYOND. ITS TO DO
THAT AND STAGES IT'S TO BUILD
FROM WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN
SUCCESSFUL THERE'S A LOT OF
ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
BEEN TESTING THE SYSTEM SINCE
TWENTY TWELVE I BELIEVE. AND SO
WE WANT TO BUILDING CAPITALIZE
ON THAT WHAT WORKS.
YOUR POINT ABOUT RELIABILITY IS
SPOT ON OF IT NEEDS TO BE SAFE
IT NEEDS TO DEMONSTRATE THAT IT
WILL WORK AND SO WE WANT TO
BUILD THIS OUT OVER THE NEXT OUT
OVER THE COMING YEARS. LEARN
FROM THAT ROLL OUT AND FIX
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE FIXED SO
THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT IT'S
RELIABLE.
THERE ARE SOME USERS WHERE THAT
RISK IS PERHAPS LOWER.
YOU KNOW AND.
AB OR FALSE ALARM TOLERANCE
MIGHT BE A LITTLE HIGHER THAT
WOULD BE KIND OF ONE WAY WE
WOULD LOOK AT ROLLING OUT STAGES
SO THAT WE CAN.
WORK OUT THINGS.
BEFORE IT MOVES ON TO OTHER
AREAS THAT MIGHT HAVE GREATER
RISK WITH WITH FALSE ALARMS I'M
IN TERMS OF THE FUNDING OPTIONS
WHAT WAS IMPORTANT FOR US IN THE
BUSINESS PLAN WAS TO IDENTIFY
THE PROS AND CONS. OF DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT THAT THIS COULD GO ON
A FEW A FEW.
YEARS AGO THERE WAS LEGISLATION
THAT ACTUALLY DIRECTED CALLAWAY
YES TO FIND NON GOVERNMENT FUNDS
FOR THIS THAT WAS CHANGED.
IN SUBSEQUENT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO ALLOW SOME OF THE
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT THAT WE
HAVE DONE BOTH IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND WE'RE HOPING TO DO THIS YEAR.
BUT REALLY LOOK FOR SOMETHING
STABLE.
YOU KNOW WHICH WHICH AT WHICH
MIXES.
PRIVATE SECTOR SOURCES AND
OTHER THINGS AND ALSO A LINE
WHERE IT MAKES SENSE WHERE WILL
THE BENEFITS MY IN THE SYSTEM
WHO WILL BENEFIT FROM AND HOW.
AND THEN LINE UP POTENTIAL
FUNDING SOURCES AGAINST THAT.
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT IS PROBABLY
VERY SMALL IF IT'S IF IT'S
SPREAD ABOUT DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES IN TERMS OF WHAT EACH
PERSON MIGHT EXPECT BUT WE
WANTED TO BE CAREFUL TO REALLY.
KIND OF LOOK AT THE PROS AND
CONS AND LINE UP BENEFITS WITH
THE COST OF ITS OF THAT MADE
SENSE WHATEVER WE DID. AND SO
NOW AND THAT'S ANOTHER AREA WERE
ALREADY WORKING ON THAT WE'VE
HAD.
INFORMAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
MANY INDUSTRIES ON THERE'S A LOT
OF INTEREST IN THE SYSTEM WE'VE
TALKED A LOT WITH. VARIOUS.
.
INDUSTRIES ABOUT THE BENEFITS
OF THE SYSTEM WE'VE SEEN IT WORK
IN OTHER COUNTRIES WITH
EARTHQUAKES THAT HAVE HAPPENED
IN JAPAN WITH MEXICO CITY. AND
SO THERE IS A LOT BEHIND THIS
AND THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST IN
CALIFORNIA AND NOW ARE ARE ARE
NOW THAT THE BUSINESS PLAN IS
OUT OUR INTENT. IS TO NOW GO AND
TAKE A DEEPER DIVE HAVE VERY
DELIBERATE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW
WE MIGHT FIND THIS WITH
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES THAT. MIGHT
BE ASKED TO FIND IT AND THEN
WORK WITH YOU OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN AND.
IN SHORT ORDER TO IDENTIFY WHAT
WHAT.
WHICH OF THOSE MIGHT WORK IN
AND GET THAT FINALIZED SO
THERE'S A LOT THAT'S THAT'S
MOVING FORWARD THE BUSINESS PLAN
RELIGIOUS IS THAT.
ARTICULATE SORT OF WHERE WE'VE
BEEN AND WHERE WE'RE GOING AND.
AND.
YOU KNOW CALLAWAY ESSES
COMPLETELY INTENTION ON ON
MOVING FORWARD ON ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WORK WITH
YOU OKAY IN THE FUTURE. INCOME
TO FINANCE
FELLOW. MOWING CURSING AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC CONCERNS
ON THE FUNDING AMOUNT BUT.
WE CAN CURRENT WHAT'S BEEN
MENTIONED EARLIER BY THE CHAIR
AND OTHERS.
WE DO HAVE THE BUSINESS PLAN
NOW HOWEVER THERE IS A LACK OF
SPECIFICITY THERE IN TERMS OF.
EXACTLY WHAT THAT MIX OF FUNDING
SOURCES WILL BE ANSWERED OF WHAT
HOW THEY SHOULD BE STRUCTURED
AND.
SO I THINK THERE'S THAT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO WANT TO
CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND OVERSEE
AND CERTAINLY PLAYS INTO THIS.
BETTER QUESTIONS WHILE I'M WE
THINK IT'S PROBABLY REASONABLE
FOR THE GENERAL FUND TO BEAR A
PORTION OF THE COST BECAUSE
THERE'S PROBABLY THAT PROBABLY
IS A GENERAL BENEFIT TO THE
SYSTEM. BUT IT'S HARD TO TELL
EXACTLY WHAT THAT BENEFITTED
BECAUSE IT SORT OF WE HAVEN'T
DONE.
QUITE THE WORK NECESSARY TO
REALLY ASSESS HOW MUCH IS
GENERAL BENEFIT VERSUS BENEFIT
FROM UP FOR THESE SPECIFIC
INDIVIDUAL INDUSTRIES SO. I'M
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT.
I THINK THERE'S CONTINUED WORK
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN BUT.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
CONCERNS WITH WITH THE PROPOSAL
IS LAID OUT.
ANY ITEM AND PUBLIC COMMENT.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS HERE
DAVIS.
DURING THE.
PROPOSAL.
OKAY SO OBVIOUSLY THERE LOT OF
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE BEEN AND
THAT. I WITH REGARDS TO.
ESTABLISHING O. WHO THE PARTNERS
ARE IN AND HOW MUCH
RESPONSIBILITY THEY BEAR AND
RESOURCES AND SO FORTH AND SO ON.
YOUR REQUEST IS FOR WHAT AT THIS
POINT SIXTEEN MILLION FIFTEEN
POINT SEVEN FIVE FIFTEEN POINT
SEVEN. OKAY AND.
.
AND THAT'S JUST TO GET STARTED
NO THAT'S ACTUALLY TO FINISH UP
THE BUILD OUT OF THE SEISMIC
STATIONS WE NEED ABOUT ELEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN.
WE'VE GOTTEN ABOUT HALF OF
THOSE FILLED WITH THE SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN BUDGET AUGMENTATION
ABOUT SIX POINT FOUR MILLION.
WAS PUT TOWARDS I'M GETTING THAT
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE MORE IN
THE GROUNDS ABOUT SEVENTY
PERCENT COMPLETED SO THIS WOULD
BE TO ACTUALLY COMPLETE THE
SYSTEM BUILT OUT.
AND AND IF I MIGHT THERE'S ALSO
ANOTHER CAPITAL COMPONENT IN
ADDITION TO THE SENSOR ROLL OUT
I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER ABOUT
SIXTEEN MILLION AS WELL. ON
EVERYTHING A SIXTEEN BIT IN THIS
PROPOSAL.
AND SO THERE IS ANOTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE COMPONENT COMING
OUT RIGHT YEAH SO THIS IS THIS
WOULD FINISH THE SENSORS AND
THERE WOULD BE SOME ADDITIONAL
CAPITAL COSTS AND THEN THERE'S.
THIS PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES AN
ONGOING COMPONENT OF ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND AS WELL
THAT WOULD FUND THE STAFFING
COSTS BUT THERE'S ALSO A
EXPECTED TO BE SOME ADDITIONAL
ITEMS. PRETTY AB BUT IT'S A
SUBSTANTIAL ONGOING COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SYSTEM AND I
THINK THAT'S PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST COMPONENT.
THAT WILL HAVE TO FIGURE OUT.
AS PART OF THIS DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHAT THE ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCES ARE GOING TO BE.
SO THE ASSUMPTION IS THEM THAT
YOU WILL OBVIOUSLY BE BACK FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
WITH THIS PROJECT.
WELL OUR TO OUR WE WE WANT TO DO
NOW IS LOOK AT FUNDING OPTIONS
THAT ARE PERHAPS NOT
GOVERNMENTAL THAT CAN. FIND THE
REST OF THE CAPITAL COST AS WELL
AS THE RECURRING.
BUT ALSO LEVERAGE WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ABLE TO
PROVIDE.
AGAIN THEY WERE APPROPRIATED.
THIS YEAR.
SOME OF THAT MONEY IS GOING TO
COME BACK TO CALIFORNIA THAT'S
PART OF OUR AGREEMENT THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON WITH THAT WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN LEVERAGE THAT TO
THE. TO THE MAXIMUM SO THAT THE
STATE DOLLARS IN FEDERAL DOLLARS
ARE WORKING TOGETHER. OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU NO QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN.
AND THAT BRINGS US TO THE AYE
MEMBER ITEM THE.
WE'VE.
HEARD MISTER ONE OF THEM
BECAUSE OF THE.
THE CONCERN THAT OF ME HAD TO
LEAVE WE HAVE WE HAVE FOLKS
SIGNED IN.
AND OUR FIRST SIGNING THIS WAS
RADIUS.
YES.
WE GIVE EACH MEMBER ABOUT FIVE
TO TEN MINUTES TO TELL US A
PROJECT.
AND.
.
TWO THREE LINDA SO.
OKAY YES.
COMMEMORATE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I FIRST WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO TRULY CONSIDER. THIS
IMPERATIVE REQUEST.
THIS REQUEST OF ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD UPON
PASSIVE PASSAGE OF AB THREE ZERO
SEVEN SIX
CREATIVE FONTS WHEN SURE THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. OF OUR
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES WHO FIND
THEMSELVES IN CHILD WELFARE
RELATED CASES.
HAVE LEGAL REPRESENTATION WHEN
THEY CANNOT AFFORD IT.
THIS IS CRUCIAL TO ENSURING THE
CHILDREN ARE NOT BEING RIPPED
AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILIES IN
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES UNNECESSARILY.
AND WILL INCREASE CALIFORNIA'S
COMPLIANCE WITH A QUORUM
STANDARDS.
NATIONALLY THERE WERE TWO
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN APPEALED A
COURT CASES OR INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT CASES IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO LEAD THE NATION IN
IKORA.
PEELS WITH ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO OF THESE APPEALS
THE SECOND STATE BEING ALASKA
WITH SIX APPEALED CASES.
ACCORDING TO THE ECHO COMPLIANCE
TASK FORCE REPORT PRESENTED TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
ESTABLISHING THIS FUND WILL
DRAMATICALLY DECREASE.
THE APPEALS CALIFORNIA HAS
RELATING TO INQUIRE AND TRIBAL
CHILD WELFARE AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY WILL PUT PROTECT
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES FROM
UNNECESSARY HARM AND TRAUMA.
I GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND HEARING THIS REQUEST AND
YOUR CONSIDERATION IN ASSURING
THAT THESE CHILDREN RECEIVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR JUSTICE
WITH ME I HAVE DELIA SHARP. WITH
A CALTRAIN TRIBAL FAMILIES
COALITION TO SPEAK MORE ON THE
ISSUE.
THANK YOU AARON EFFECTIVE THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA. AND I
AM.
CERTAINLY ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR HEARING THIS
REQUEST
I AM I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL FAMILIES
COALITION WHICH IS THE SUCCESSOR
ORGANIZATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
EQUIP COMPLIANCE TASK FORCE
WHICH WAS CONVENED. I'M AT THE
INVITATION OF ATTORNEY GENERAL
HARRIS IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SPECIFICALLY TO LOOK ADEQUATE
COMPLIANCE. AND THIS IS ONE OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THAT
TASK FORCE MADE. UP IN THE
REPORT IN THAT.
THROUGH THE CURRENT
ORGANIZATION WE CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW UP ON. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT CONGRESS PASSED TO
ACQUIRE THE INDIAN CHILD WELFARE
ACT TO PROTECT THE INTERESTS OF
TROUBLED CHILDREN AND PROMOTE
STABILITY AND SECURITY FOR
TRIBES AND THEIR MEMBER FAMILIES.
HOWEVER STATE COURTS AND COUNTY
AGENCIES CONTINUE TO ILLUSTRATE
SERIOUS LACK OF COMPLIANCE WITH
THAT PLAN.
AB THREE ZERO THREE ZERO SEVEN
SIX REQUIRES THE STATE BAR TO
OFFER GRANTS TO QUALIFIED
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATIONS. SO THAT ADEQUATE
LEGAL SERVICES CAN BE PROVIDED
TO INDIAN TRIBES AND CHILD
WELFARE CASES WHERE THE INDIAN
CHILD WELFARE ACT APPLIES.
FUNDING CONSTRAINTS ARE ONE OF
THE MAIN REASONS TRIBES LACK THE
CAPACITY TO HANDLE IT WHAT
ELIGIBLE CASES.
CURRENTLY IN A CHILD WELFARE
CASE.
MOM AND DAD AND THE MINOR IN THE
COUNTY ARE ALL APPOINTED COUNCIL
THE TRIBE IS THE SOUL AYE AND
REPRESENTED PARTY IN THOSE CASES
OFTEN BEING REPRESENTED. BY A
TRIBAL SOCIAL WORKER RATHER THAN
AN ATTORNEY CREATING TREMENDOUS
DIFFICULTY ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
AUTHORIZING LEGAL ASSISTANCE TO
TRIBES WILL INCREASE COMPLIANCE
AND OVERALL REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
APPEALS RELATED TO EQUIP CASES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS
FROM ANYONE AUDIENCE.
WE SHOULD NAME AND YOUR.
.
WHETHER AND SUPPORTERS WANT TO
HEAR THIS. YEAH POETRY ON BEHALF
OF BOTH THE CHUNGA ANDCOLUSA
INDIAN TRIBES ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS FUNDING.
AS I HAVE.
HAVE TALKED OTHERS BEFORE OF.
THE GAMING TRAVELS TO THE GAMING
TRIBES CAN AFFORD GOOD ATTORNEYS
THEY HAVE IN HOUSE ATTORNEYS BUT
FOR THE MAJORITY THE HUNDRED
EIGHT TRIBES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY DON'T HAVE IN
HOUSE ATTORNEYS WHO ACTUALLY CAN
HELP THEM GET THROUGH THESE
CASES. AND FOR THE INDIAN
CHILDREN WE VERY MUCH ASK YOU TO
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BUDGET.
KRISTIN PARA ALLIANCE FOR JONES
WRITES IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS LUNCH FROM CALIFORNIA
TRIBAL BUSINESS ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
MEMBERS OF THAT IS THE QUESTION.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WITH
THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN.
OKAY OUR NEXT PERSON IS MISTER
LACKEY
.
ALRIGHT WELL THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND A COMMITTEE MEMBERS
STAKE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS TRAILER BILL.
OF.
WHICH WILL LOCK AND CONFORM TO
CURRENT CALIFORNIA DO I LAWS
WITH THE RECENT RULINGS MADE BY
THE SUPREME COURT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
CALIFORNIA'S DO WHILE LAWS ARE
CURRENTLY NOT A COMPLIANCE WITH
THE DUE PROCESS REQUIREMENTS.
SET FORTH BY THE SUPREME COURT
OF THE UNITED STATES IN THE
BIRCH FILLED VERSES NORTH DAKOTA
CASE.
THE COURT SAID THAT A STATE
CANNOT ASSESS CRIMINAL PENALTIES
FOR REFUSING A BLOOD TEST DURING
A DUI ARREST.
SO TO UPDATE THESE LAWS THIS
TRAILER BILL REQUEST.
ABSURD TO STREHLER BILL REQUEST
WILL CONFORM CALIFORNIA'S
IMPLIED CONSENT DO YOU WHY.
A TO COMPLY WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS SET FORTH BY THE
COURT.
THE LANGUAGE I'VE SUBMITTED FOR
THIS FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
CONSIDERATION IS STRICTLY
TECHNICAL.
AND ONLY CHANGES
WHAT IS REQUIRED TO BRING US
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH THE SUPREME
COURT'S RULING.
IT SIMPLY STRIKES CRIMINAL
SANCTIONS FROM OUR CODES FOR
REFUSING TO SUBMIT.
TO A BLOOD TEST WHEN UNDER THE
ARREST.
WHEN UNDER THE REST UNDER THE
SUSPICION OF A DUI.
THE NEED TO UPDATE OUR OUR
STATUTE IS IMPORTANT.
UPDATING THE STATUE WILL ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT MOTOR VEHICLES TO
UPDATE THEIR FORMS.
WHICH LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
FILL OUT DURING AN ARREST.
THIS WILL ENSURE STANDARDIZATION
ACROSS ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
JURISDICTIONS SOFTWARES ARE
COMPLYING WITH THE COURT'S
RULING.
MY OFFICE HAS INFORMED GOVERNOR
BROWN'S ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
THIS REQUEST
AND THE PORTS ARE MAKING THIS
CHANGE.
I DID ATTEMPT UPDATE THE STATUTE
LAST YEAR AND SOME OF THE BILL
SEVEN OH TWO HOWEVER. THERE ARE
ANCILLARY ISSUES OUTSIDE OF THE
COURT'S RULING THE CONSTANT
CONFUSION.
THAT'S WHY I FEEL THIS IS AN
APPROPRIATE STATUE CHANGE FOR
BUDGET TRAILER BILL BECAUSE IT
AS NOTED BEFORE. THIS LANGUAGE
DOES NOTHING MORE THAN UPDATE
THE STATUTE.
THAT WERE INVALIDATED BY THE
SUPREME COURT'S RULING.
IT DOES NOT DELVE INTO THE OTHER
ISSUES THE BOG DOWN A. B. SEVEN
OH TO.
AND I'M ABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
IF YOU WISH YOU HAD SOMETHING
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND I JUST
BRIEFLY I SHOT UP WITH
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WAS IN SUPPORT OF
THE STATUTORY CHANGE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY SAID THIS
REALLY IS.
S. CONFORMING CALIFORNIA LAW
WITH WHICH REQUIRED NOW IN THE
WAKE OF THE BURCHFIELD DECISION.
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC.
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
MISSUS DONA QUESTION.
I DO BECAUSE THEY'RE MEMBER YOUR
SEVEN OF TWO AND THAT'S
IN THE SENATE CORRECT.
NO BUT IT IT NO LONGER HELEN'S
YEAH GOT HELD ON SUSPENSE ó
OKAY. BE I WASN'T EXACTLY SURE
THE STATUS OF THAT SO BECAUSE IT
SEEMS.
STARTED THIS IS A DUMB QUESTION
MAYBE BUT THIS SEEMS LIKE POLICY
WHICH SHOULD THIS BE DONE
THROUGH A POLICY BILL RATHER
THAN BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
SO.
I GUESS WHERE WE HEAR AND WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S THE DOLLAR ASSETS.
NO THERE ISN'T THERE ISN'T
REALLY A DOLLAR ASK OTHER THAN.
THE DMV COST TO CHANGE THEIR
FORMS.
THAT THAT'S REALLY THE DOLLAR
ASK NOW THAT THAT WOULD BE
INVOLVED HERE BUT THE REASON WHY
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS
PARTICULAR PROCESS IS BECAUSE.
IT'S SIMPLER AND IT DOESN'T GET
BOGGED DOWN IN ALL THE OTHER
ACCUSATIONS THAT EXISTED WITH
SEVEN OF TWO.
AND BECAUSE WE REALLY NEED THIS
REALLY QUICKLY.
THERE'S AN URGENCY TO THIS
OKAY BUT IF THAT.
IF THIS WAS A COURT CASE THE
SUPREME COURT CASE.
THAT APPLIES THEN.
THAT IT APPLIES IN THE IN THE
LAW THAT THE STATE IS IS THE LAW.
AND I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND IT
WOULD CONCUR WITH WANTED TO
CHANGE OUR STATUTORY SCHEME.
BUT ANY COSTS THAT DB HAS
ALREADY WHAT AT THAT THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO BEAR THAT COST.
ANYWAY WHETHER WE CHANGE A
STATUTE OR NOT.
WOULD THAT BE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO.
APPLY. WITH THE SUPREME COURT
CASE.
WITHOUT THAT LAST YEAR.
OKAY.
YEAH I JUST DON'T.
WHITE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PUSHED
BACK HIS FOR WHAT THE PROBLEM IS.
AND IF THERE WHERE YOU INDICATED
THERE WERE MORE ISSUES WITH YOUR
BILL LAST YEAR THAN THAN WHAT'S
BEING ASKED FOR HERE GAP OF
WHEAT WE ALL WE GET IS TO
COMPLETELY CHANGE THE STATUTE
THE STUFF AND WE DON'T DO
ANYTHING TO END FOR ANY OTHER.
BUT THE ADVISEMENT THE WAY THE
ADVISEMENT WAS GIVING THAT WAS.
.
ALLEGING THAT THERE WAS GONNA BE
MORE REFUSALS AND OF IT WAS VERY.
HARD TO MEDIATE WRAP MY HEAD
AROUND BUT THAT WAS THE
ACCUSATION.
IT'S HAPPENED YOU KNOW I I WAS
JUST GONNA SAY IN IN SEVEN A TO
THAT DEALT WITH MORE THAN JUST
THE.
CONFORMITY THE STATUE DID BRING
INTO.
THE WE TRIED TO KIND OF
PRESCRIBE WHAT THE ADVISEMENT
NEEDED TO BE THAT OFFICER GAVE.
THAT CREATED SOME CONFLICT BOTH
WITH CHP IS WALLS WITH DEFENSE
BAR A THIS WOULD WOULD STRICTLY
BE THAT THAT STATUTORY CHANGE. I
THINK THE ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED
BY DMV LAST YEAR WITH RESPECT TO
THE COST OF OF UPDATING THIS
FORMS.
THE FORMS REFLECT WHAT THE
STATUTE SAYS NOT NECESSARILY
WHAT.
SUPREME COURT CASE LAW SAYS.
A AND SO THAT'S.
THAT'S WHERE THE WHERE THE
REBELS WITH WITH APPROPRIATIONS
WAS.
THE COST OF UPDATING THOSE FORMS.
WAS
PROBLEMATIC EDIT THE OF THE GIVE
YOUR.
ESTIMATED COST FOR THAT.
I'M SURE THEY DID I DON'T RECALL
OTHER RECALL WHAT IT IS YOU THAT
BECAUSE I I THINK FOR US TO PASS
SOMETHING.
I'M NOT NECESSARILY AGAINST
DOING POLICY IN BUDGET THIS.
IT'S WHAT WE DO IS THAT WHAT
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO BUT IT'S
WHAT WE DO. BUT I THINK GETTING
AN IDEA OF HOW MUCH WE'RE ASKING
FOR THAT'S THAT'S THE THING THAT
THAT.
THAT I DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND
SOUNDS LIKE A WORTHY PROBLEM TO
SOLVE BUT GETTING THAT. GETTING
THE NUMBERS RIGHT. AND.
I DO UNDERSTAND DMV SAYS WHAT
THE FORMS.
MATCH WHAT THE STATUTE SAYS BUT
IF THE STATUTE IS INFLUENCED BY
THE SUPREME COURT SAY THIS IS
WRONG THIS IS HOW YOU MUST ACT.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE HOW THEY SAY
OH WE SHOULD KILL THE POLICY
BILL.
BECAUSE IT COSTS THEM.
MONEY THAT IT YOU ARE NOT SURE
HOW IT HAPPENED BUT IT DID SO I
OKAY OKAY SO I TO ME TO GO DOWN.
TO US TO RATTLE HERE BUT I SAW
THIS AND WAS TRYING TO.
THE SONG HAS TOGETHER BECAUSE I
THINK I REMEMBER SEVENTY TWO
WHEN IT WAS WHAT THEY WANT. OUR
HOUSE LAST YEAR BUT.
OKAY INTERRUPTED SO SIMPLE.
DOESN'T YET BUT TURNED OUT TO BE
A LITTLE CYCLE GOING THROUGH
HERE WE'RE GONNA NEED. TO
UNDERTAKE OKAY WHAT THE MONEY IS
I WOULD THINK IN ORDER FOR US TO
BE MAKING A RECOMMENDATION.
SUCH A FAT OUT OF ANY ONE
ATTENDED THE APPS THAT WE'VE
HEARD TODAY.
THAT'S A FRACTION.
SORRY SMALL AMOUNT.
ALMOST WHAT I CAN TO AT I KNOW
IT IS A PART OF IT AYE I'D.
BUT THERE WAS SOME MONEY
ATTACHED BUT ITS BASICALLY A
POLICY ISSUE.
AND SO I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT ELSE WAS IN SEVEN ó
TO THAT WAS THE HANG UP WAS AT
THE. IF YOU TRY TO PRESCRIBE
ADDITIONAL POLICY HAD TO DO WITH
THE ADVISEMENT THAT'S THEN GIVEN.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE.
DIFFERENT PENALTIES FOR REFUSING
THE CHEMICAL TEST VERSES THE OF
THE BOOK THE BLOOD TEST VERSUS
THE BREATH TEST.
AND WHAT THAT NEEDED TO BE AND
WHETHER WE SHOULD SPECIFY IN
STATUTE WHAT IT IS OR SORT OF.
TIME TO GIVE THAT THE KEY POINTS
IN STATUTE AND LEAVE IT UP TO
THE OFFICERS INTERPRETATION WHEN
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GIVING THAT
ADVISEMENT.
AND THAT.
YOU KNOW WE COULD MAKE ANYBODY
HAPPY. SO I ASSUME THEN THAT THE
THAT THE CURRENT THAT THE THE
LANGUAGE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
NOW.
WHICH IS ABSENT OF THOSE THINGS
PROBABLY COULD GET TO POLICY
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S UNKNOWN.
PERHAPS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
HIM THEY WOULD PROBABLY PASS
POLICY MAY GET HELD.
APPROACH ROADS NAMES WEBSITE IN
WHICH WILL TELL THE LAST TIME
RIGHT WHICH WHICH WHICH WHICH IS
THE DISCONNECT BECAUSE IF
THERE'S A SUPREME COURT CASE AND
THIS IS HOW YOU WOULD ACT. IT
JUST SEEMS THAT WE'RE DOING THE
PUBLIC A DISSERVICE.
BY NOW MAKE SURE THE FORMS ARE
IN ACCORDANCE WITH YOU AND I
WOULD AGREE ON THAT THE LAW
WHETHER IT'S FEDERAL LAW OF
STATE LAW OR RIGHT.
THROUGH COURT SO THAT. THAT'S
WHAT HAS JUST WE JUST DON'T
WANNA RISK IT THAT'S WHY WE'RE
GOING THIS ON THE PATH OKAY.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY
THAT BRINGS US NOT TO MISS TO
FLORA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLOOR.
GOOD LATE AFTERNOON. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AND THANKS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO TESTIFY.
I MEAN I REQUEST THAT YOUR
COMMITTEE CONSIDERED BUDGET
AUGMENTATION FOR TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE GENERAL
FUND TO THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH AND
ADMINISTER. AND NEW SMART
FIREFIGHTING PILOT PROGRAM.
THIS MONEY WOULD BE USED
ESTABLISHED APART PILOT PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE SELECT FIRE
DEPARTMENT A GRANT TO ACQUIRE
AND DEPLOY SMART FIRE FIGHTING
EQUIPMENT.
AS ALL OF US KNOW CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHER EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL RESPONDED MILLIONS OF
REQUESTS EACH YEAR.
FIRST MYERS NEED EVERY ADVANTAGE
DURING LIFE POTENTIALLY LIFE
THREATENING OPERATIONS.
FIRE DEPARTMENT OF AND WORK WITH
TECH COMPANIES TO DEVELOP NEW
EQUIPMENT.
TO PROVIDE JUST THAT NASA'S JET
PROPULSION LAB.
DEVELOPING AUDREY.
AN ARTIFICIAL TOLD THE SYSTEM
DESIGNED.
DAVID NUMEROUS DEVICES AND
SENSORS FOR FIRST RESPONDER
COMMUNICATION.
AND CASES.
IN THE CASE OF FIRE PRIZES WILL
INCLUDE GPS HEAT GAS AND
CHEMICAL SENSORS AND EVEN
SATELLITE IMAGERY OF THEIR
LOCATION.
THE TECHNOLOGY WOULD GIVE
FIREFIGHTERS EVERY TOOL AT THEIR
DISPOSAL TO ENSURE THEIR SAFETY
AND THE SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC.
THIS FUNDING WOULD EXPAND THE
STATE'S EFFORT TO IMPROVE THE
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM BY INVESTING
IN TECHNOLOGY THAT WOULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND FIREFIGHTING
EFFORTS.
I WOULD LIKE NOTE WE HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF CONSUMERS FIRE
DEPARTMENT WHOSE PLAN TO BE HERE
TODAY BUT WERE UNABLE TO TESTIFY
DUE TO A HEAVY WORKLOAD. AGAIN
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR TIME AND ATTENTION
TO THIS IMPORTANT MATTER.
OKAY.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE PUBLIC COMMENT.
ANY QUESTION FOR MEMBERSHIP THE
DAIS CONCERNING THIS.
OKAY THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
THAT BRINGS US TO A STEINORTH.
HERE NO.
OF GARCIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND CHEN
COLLEAGUES AFTERNOON WE HAVE
FOUGHT THREE REQUESTS
NOT AT.
BEFORE YOU TODAY OF FOR THE IT'S
OKAY WITH YOU ALL START WITH THE
NATIONAL COMPLY THE NETWORK.
I REQUEST FOR THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
TYPICALLY THE FUNDING THAT WOULD
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM IN THE
COUNTIES OF ALAMEDA IMPERIAL LOS
ANGELES RIVERSIDE SAN DIEGO
SANTA. SANTA CLARENCEUX KEEN FOR
CULTURAL REENTRY SERVICES.
AND SUPPORT PERSONS WHO OUR OR
ARE SCHEDULED TO BE RELEASED
FROM THE COUNTY JAIL.
THE NATIONAL COMPANY'S NETWORK
AS IF I ONCE HE THREE NONPROFIT
WAS ASIAN AND HAS BUILT ITS
REPUTATION ON THE BALLOT BE
MODEL PROGRAMS WRITING TRAINING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
BUILDING CAPACITY. OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COMMUNITIES
IN THIS AREA.
THEY'VE HELD AND TO CONTINUE TO.
FACILITATE
A NUMBER OF GRANTS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE SAME ISSUES THAT
I'VE JUST HIGHLIGHTED. AND THAT
IS OUR FIRST I REQUEST AND THERE
MIGHT BE SOMEONE IN THE AUDIENCE
WHO WANTS TO JUST.
SAY ME TOO I THINK THIS SOMEONE
FROM OF IN SUPPORT OF THE
COMPADRE NETWORK.
WITH THE JUST A STATEMENT OF ME
TO A LOT MICROPHONE THERE.
AFTERNOON ARE MANY DETECTOR PENS
PARTICULAR REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL COMPOSITE NETWORK.
WE WERE DISSECTED URGED OF THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT US ARE
PHILOSOPHY IS OF LIKE A
POLITICAL DOWN WHICH IS A
TRANSFORMATION HEALTH AND
HEALING PHILOSOPHY.
THAT IS CULTURE BASED FRAMEWORK
BILLS ON AN ETCH OPPORTUNITY
FACTORS ON WHAT IS HEALTHY
WITHIN AN INDIVIDUAL FAMILY
COMMUNITY AND CULTURE.
THE DISHES BASED ALERT LIFE VIEW
PROMOTES THAT THE RIGHT BASED ON
CULTURAL GROUNDS PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL MENTAL AND SPIRITUAL
PRINCIPLES AND PRACTICE.
SO WE THINK YOU URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT US THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MEDINA SALMON
UNISOM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
FATHERS ABOUT JUST HOW WALKING
WHEN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
WILL ENCOURAGE YOU TO.
.
AND SUPPORT THE FATHERS THAT HER
REENTRY.
ON THE PALLET THIS PROGRAM.
THE CALIBER HEALTHCARE FACILITY
WITH GREAT GREAT RESULTS.
ARMED AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
THEY'RE NOT JUST FELONS ARE
FATHERS IN THEIR ON THE
RECONCILIATION THAT THIS
PROVIDES THEM IS VERY ESSENTIAL
AND REENTRY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CAN WE GO FROM HERE JUSTICE
COALITION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS FROM OUR WELCOME HOME
PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE COMING HOME
FROM PRISON. STRONG SUPPORT AND
THINK YOU'RE OF CONSIDERATION.
AFTERNOON ANNA JOHNSON NATIONAL
CENTER FEW FLAWED SUPPORT.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE VARIOUS.
OKAY FINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS ATTACK YOU ATTENTION ON
THAT LATTER EX I DON'T.
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE YEAH
CALIFORNIA GANG CRIME AND
VIOLENCE PREVENTION PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. THAT WAS CREATED IN
ORDER TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN THAT JOINT AND
PARTICIPATING GANGS THIS IS A
PROGRAM. THAT FOCUSES ON
SUPPORTING COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS IN CITIES WITH
HIGH IN THIS IS A GANG VIOLENCE
IN ORDER TO PREVENT RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS BY GANGS. TOWARDS OUR
VULNERABLE YOUTH
UNFORTUNATE PROGRAM WAS.
.
KIND OF ITS FUNDING SOMETIME AGO
WERE ASKING FOR FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO GET THIS UP AND GOING
AGAIN WE HAVE A NUMBER OF.
COLLEAGUES BOTH IN THE SENATE
AND IN THE ASSEMBLY THAT HAVE
JOINED IN THIS RISK REQUEST.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION ON
THIS MATTER AS WELL.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE
SIGNED THIS PROJECT.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THIS.
IS THIS IS IS THIS THAT WE HAD
ANOTHER REQUEST GAME REQUEST TO.
CAL CAL GRIP CAO GANGS AND AND
AND THE LEVEL OF. JAIL VIP IN
THIS IS A DIFFERENT ONE.
THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA GANG
CRIME AND VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
SO QUE.
ALRIGHT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU RIGHT.
OF THE OTHER ONE IS SO YOU HAVE
ONE FOR THE ARTS IS THE PURE YES
AND THIS ARM OF JUSTICE. THAT'S
CORRECT THIS IS A REQUEST FOR A
GROUP OF FIVE MILLION.
FOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SUPPORT THE NEW BUREAU OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
PROGRAM AT THAT WOULD BE HOUSE
THERE IN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE.
THE CREATION OF THE EBAY BUREAU
IS A BIG STEP FORWARD. A TO
ADDRESSING ABOUT MY JUSTICE
ISSUES AND COMMUNITIES ARE JUST
PART
PROPORTIONALLY IMPACTED.
BY POLLUTION. AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR UC'S
CONSIDERATION ON THIS MATTER AS
WELL.
THE COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARIO DIBERNARDO ON HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAVEA SARAH.
ARE THE AGE YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT.
OR THANK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA FOR
MAKING THIS REQUEST TO SUPPORT
AND EXPAND. THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE BUREAU WITH PERMANENT
POSITIONS.
THE AG SUPPORTS THIS REQUESTS
AND WE ASK THE COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE IT THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY.
THOUGHT FROM THE AREA AGS TO
HAUNT YOU HE PRIORITIZES THIS
REQUEST IN RELATIONSHIP TO BE
UPS.
THIS MAY.
THIS IS A MEMBER REQUESTS ó
OKAY.
ALRIGHT.
THEY WON'T TELL ME OPENNESS.
IT.
IT WAS CLEVER O. IN HE COULD ANY
COMMENTS YOU HAVE THAT THIS IS A
QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU PRETENTIOUS.
WE HAVE STEINORTH HERE.
STEINORTH IS HERE YES OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR. IN
NEW. A READY FOR ME TO PROCEED
YES WE'RE READY VERY GOOD THANK
YOU. I'M THINK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT ITS
IMPORTANT BUDGET REQUEST ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AS WELL AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GRAY AND
ASSEMBLYMAN AND SALAS.
WE'RE REQUESTING FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND THE PROTECT OUR
HOMES PILOT PROGRAM WHICH WOULD
ALLEVIATE HARDSHIP ON STRUGGLING
CALIFORNIANS WHO MUST CHOOSE
BETWEEN BASIC NEEDS AND HOME
SECURITY.
THIS MODEST AMOUNT OF MONEY
WOULD PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WHO
QUALIFY FOR EITC AND THE
COUNTIES OF KINGS CURRENT MERCED
AND STAMINA DINO WITH GRANTS UP
TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS TO
PURCHASE HOME SECURITY EQUIPMENT.
STUDIES SHOW THAT BURGLARY
OCCURS MOST COMMONLY AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WITH HIGH
RATES OF UNEMPLOYMENT LEAVING
THESE RESIDENTS PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO HOME INVASIONS.
IN THE COUNTY SERVED BY THIS
PROGRAM RESIDENTS EXPERIENCE
POVERTY RATES WELL ABOVE THE
STATE AVERAGE WHILE ALSO FACING
HIGHER RATES OF BURGLARY.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST SECURITY
SYSTEM COST UPWARDS OF TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS FORCING
RESIDENTS LIVING NEAR THE
POVERTY LINE TO MAKE THE CHOICE
BETWEEN HOME SAFETY. AND OTHER
BASIC NEEDS TOOL THING
SURE THE FAMILY SAFETY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU SUPPORT.
YOUR SUPPORT AND FUNDING THE
PROTECT OUR HOMES PILOT PROGRAM.
FOR ANY COMMENTS FROM ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE.
MEMBERS.
WITH DON'T.
JUST A QUESTION SINCE THE
CAPITAL EXPENDITURE WHICH IS
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR IS
USUALLY A SMALL PART OF.
THE REAL COST OF SECURITY SYSTEM.
WHAT'S THE THOUGHT OF OF HOW DO
THESE PEOPLE THAN PAY FOR THE
MONTHLY COST THE CONNECTIONS
THAT.
THEY MAY OR MAY NOT EVEN HAVE
ADEQUATE BROADBAND TO BE ABLE TO
CARRY THE SIGNAL. SOS IS THIS
HOW HOW DOES THIS WORK.
WELL WHAT WE DO GOOD QUESTIONS
THAT FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE HAVE TAILORED THIS
BILL DOWN FROM ITS ORIGINAL
CONCEPT TO TRY AND FIT WITHIN
THE BUDGET THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
FOR THE THE COUNTIES THAT WERE
TRYING TO EXPAND THE PILOT
PROGRAM FOR. I'M ORIGINALLY IN
ITS.
INCARNATION IT DID LOOK AT A
LARGE AMOUNT THAT WOULD INCLUDE
THE COST OF MONTHLY SERVICE AS
WELL BUT AS TECHNOLOGY HAS
EVOLVED WERE NOTICING THAT.
I I DON'T MEAN TO SAY THIS IS
THE NAME OF THIS COMPANY IS A
PROMOTION FOR THIS PARTICULAR
COMPANY BUT THERE ARE DOORBELLS
NOW THAT HAVE AN ELECTRONIC
ASPECT TO IT THAT CAN COULD.
KEEP TRACK IN AND VIDEO RECORD
WHO COMES TO YOUR DOOR THAT'S
PROVIDED A GREAT LEVEL OF
SECURITY THIS PRICE POINT THAT
WERE LOOKING OUT ITS IS FULLY
WITHIN THAT COST FACTOR. THERE'S
NO ONGOING FEES THAT GO ALONG
WITH THAT IF IT WAS A
TRADITIONAL.
YOU KNOW.
HOME SECURITY COMPANY AND I
WON'T SAY AND A BRAND BECAUSE
I'M NOT SURE ADVOCATE FOR BRAND
BUT USUALLY YOU'RE LOOKING AT
RANGES BETWEEN TWENTY TO THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS PER MONTH. TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT SECURITY
COMPANY A MONITOR YOUR SERVICE
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT WHETHER THEY
HAVE BROADBAND OR NOT EACH OF
THESE COUNTIES.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS A LOT OF
THESE HOMES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
LOW COST.
INTERNET AND A LOT OF THESE.
FAMILIES ALSO HAVE THE NEEDS OF
THE INTERNET FOR THEIR CHILDREN
FOR FOR THEIR WORK AT SCHOOL SO
I WOULD BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW
ALL THOSE STARS ALIGNED THAT
THIS WOULD BE A GOOD PROJECT.
OKAY BECAUSE I MEAN THAT SOME OF
THE SIGNALS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
DOES.
DOES TAKE VIDEO IT'S GONNA TAKE
VIDEO OUT OVER THE INTERNET
WHICH.
WHICH ASSUMES A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF.
BI DIRECTIONAL DATA AND FOR A
LOT OF THIS IS ONE OF THE FIGHTS
WE'VE BEEN HAVING WITH. THAT
TELECOM INDUSTRY IF YOU'RE ONLY
TALKING IF YOU'RE LIMITED TO SIX
MEGABITS DOWN ONE MINUTE MEGABIT
UP.
I'M NOT SURE HOW WELL THAT WORKS
IN THAT ENVIRONMENT I DID SO I
JUST TRY TO GET MY HEAD AROUND
WHAT EXACTLY. WOULD BE ABLE TO
BE PURCHASED ON THAT SAID.
AND TO UNDERSTAND UTILITY BUT
THANKS.
OKAY. CRICKET AND ALSO THE THAT
I THINK THE ONGOING TOSSES
ALWAYS A VARIABLE AND SOMETIMES
THESE AGENCIES WILL GIVE YOU
FREE EQUIPMENT BECAUSE THEN YOU
HAVE TO.
PURCHASE THIS SERVICES FOR EVERY
MONTH AS WELL AS PAID THE FEE TO
THE.
POLICE DEPARTMENT TO MONITOR
YOUR HOME FOR THEM TO COME OUT
THEY CHARGE YOU A A LICENSE FEE
OR SOMETHING EVERY EVERY OF THE
YEAR. RECESS NOW THAT'S THE ONES
I HAVE TO ACCEPT IT BE
INTERESTING BUT THIS IS SO SO
THIS INVOLVES THREE DIFFERENT.
AB MEMBERS YES THAT'S CORRECT MY
MY.
LARA GRAY AND WILL KNOW THIS
ACTUALLY ASIDE THIS WOULD BE
SALAS GROUNDS NINE DOLLARS GRAY
AND MYSELF USE OF OKAY. ALRIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I PLEDGE
NOT THREE BUT FIVE MILLION
THAT'S CRACKED QUE ALRIGHT MISS
EGGMAN THANK YOU VERY YOU KNOW
WHO.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS HER
AFTERNOON GOOD MORNING HOW GOT
DEJA VU HOA GROUNDHOG DAY.
.
I'M HERE FOR A ONE TIME REQUEST.
OF THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
HELICOPTER FOR THE CITY OF
STOCKTON.
ANYBODY WHO'S BEEN AROUND ANY
TIME KNOW THAT I WAS ON THE CITY
COUNCIL WE HAD TO GO INTO
BANKRUPTCY THE DARKEST TIMES IN
AND OUR HISTORY A TWO THOUSAND
AND TWELVE.
AND DURING THAT TIME BEFORE WE
WENT THERE WE HADN'T.
WE WERE ABLE TO GET NEGOTIATIONS
WITH ALL OF OUR LABOR GROUPS OF
FOUR BUT IT WAS A LOT OF PAIN
GOING INTO THAT WERE CRIME ROSE
VERY HIGH AA WHERE ARE. OUR
MURDER RATE WAS AT THE HIGHEST
IN HISTORY WE NEVER HAVE WHERE
WALKING AROUND OUTSIDE.
PUBLICLY
THAT PEOPLE FELT UNSAFE
AND THAT THAT THOSE FEELINGS
STICK WITH ME. SINCE THEN WE'LL%
BECOMING WE'RE WE'RE BACK ON THE
RIGHT WHERE WE ARE COMING BACK.
UP AND LAST YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THE VOTERS OF STOCKTON
VOTED TO TAX THEMSELVES.
OFFER PUBLIC SAFETY BOTH FOR
HIRING MORE POLICE OFFICERS AND
FOR THEM INVESTING IN THINGS
LIKE COMMUNITY CENTERS AND
LIBRARIES TO TRY TO. DO
COMMUNITIES A SUPPORT IN ALL
KINDS OF WAYS.
WHEN THE THINGS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO AND AND WHEN I TELL
PEOPLE DON'T LIVE IN A CITY OUR
SIZE WE DON'T WORK WITH THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE NOW. A WE DON'T HAVE A
HELICOPTER TO HELP WITH THE
POLICING ISSUES.
WE ARE ON THE NORTHERN END OF.
OF THAT DATA CENTRE VALLABH
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AREA SO THE
CLOSEST HELICOPTERS FRESNO AND
ON THE. ON THE NORTHERN SIDE
WHERE ON THE SOUTHERN AND AND SO
THE CLOSEST PLEASE HOP
HELICOPTERED CHP. A IS IN AUBURN
STILL FOR ANY CRISIS WE HAVE
IT'LL TAKE AT LEAST THIRTY
MINUTES FOR A HELICOPTER TO BE
ABLE TO GET IN ITS PEOPLE KNOW.
HIGH SPEED CHASES A WEEK WE HAVE
OUT WE STILL HAVE A HIGH DEGREE
OF CRIME THAT WE'RE TRYING TO.
CONTINUE TO TRY TO ADDRESS.
AND. WE WE HAVE ENOUGH MONEY ONE
DAY THAT WE THEY BUDGET ONE
POINT BUT TO ONE POINT TWO FIVE
MILLION A YEAR WE CAN PAY FOR
THE OPERATIONS WE CAN PAY FOR
THE STAFFING WE CAN PAY FOR ALL
THE TRAINING. WE JUST NEED THAT
ONETIME INFUSION. A OF A OF A
HELICOPTER THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT ONLY HAS A A FIXED
FIXED WING CRAFT. FOAM.
THE DRONES GOING UP SOMETIMES A
YOU KNOW THAT THE NGUYEN FACTORS
WILL WELL OVER THE BATTERIES
FACTORS WILL WILL AFFECT THEM.
.
ALSO IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
PEOPLE MIGHT RECALL WE HAD.
ONE OF THE LARGEST UP LEAST
THEM SHOOT OUTS OVER SIX HUNDRED
SHOTS FIRED BY THE STOCK POLICE
DEPARTMENT WITH THE HOSTAGE.
SITUATION TAKEN OF THAT HOSTAGE
ENDED UP LOSING HER LIFE AS USE
IT AS A HUMAN SHIELD BY THE
PEOPLE WHO ROB THAT THAT BANK.
ARM SO.
IN LOOKING AT ALL OF THOSE
THINGS AND WE HAVE TRIED IN
DIFFERENT WAYS TO COME UP WITH
THE MONEY INTERNALLY BUT WE JUST
FEEL LIKE THIS IS A GOOD ONE
TIME REQUEST. OF FOR CITY THAT
IS REALLY BACK ON THE RISE AND
HAS INVESTED IN ITSELF IT'S
VOTERS HAVE. BEEN INVESTED IN
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS IS COMING OUT AND
SAYING THIS WOULD REALLY BE
HELPFUL TO REDUCE CRIME. TO TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE SAFETY TOM
SOAP THAT'S OUR ASK WHY HAVE
CURE ROSS HERO LOBBIES FOR THE
CITY STOCKTON AND US FORGET
RICHARD BUCKLEY FROM THE CITY OF
STOCKTON.
GOOD EVENING CARE ALSO BE UP HE
CITY OF STOCKTON ALICE REITERATE
THIS IS THE TWELFTH LARGEST CITY
IN CALIFORNIA SECOND HIGHEST
CRIME RATE. THERE DO NOT HAVE
ANY AIR SUPPORT WITH THE COUNTY
DOES NOT HAVE.
HELICOPTER WE THINK THAT THIS
CAN DO A LOT OF GREAT THINGS
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY NOT JUST
FOR IN SUPPLIES INCIDENTS THAT
OCCUR BUT REALLY ALSO PRO
PRESENCE IN THE COMMITTEE CAN
REALLY WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY
INTO A LOT OF GREAT THINGS.
THERE IS SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY
WANTS THIS THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S COMING TOP DOWN THIS IS.
THE COMMUNITY IT'S IS STRONGLY
SUPPORT ABOUT THAT SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR APPROVAL OF THIS ITEM.
EFFECTIVE. I'M RICHARD BUCKLEY
I'M A SERGEANT WAS TALKING
PLEASE PERMIT AND I'M HERE
ANSWER IN TECHNICAL ACTIONS
MIGHT HAVE.
AND I UNDERSTAND THEY DO HAVE
SOMEONE TO FLY THE HELICOPTERS
GONNA BE WONDERING. YOU ONE OF
THE PEOPLE I AM NOT YOU KNOW NO
I I START THE PROCESS OF
TRAINING FOR THAT BUT WE
ACTUALLY DO HAVE AN INSTRUCTOR
PILOT THAT LARRY THAT'S A YOU
KNOW THEY ASKED THE QUESTION DO
YOU HAVE THE ONE FLAT IS. AND
THEY SAID YES OKAY DID YOU
PRISON LAST WEEK IT ANY OUT ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
PUBLIC COMMENTS INCOMES FROM
MEMBERS OF THE DAVIS.
ANOTHER QUESTION.
AS A SUB NUMBER FOUR.
A WITH THE STATE IS ACTUALLY UP
PURCHASED OF.
.
EQUIPMENT EQUIPMENT OF THIS
NATURE FOR THE MUNICIPALITY.
HI.
THIRTEEN BUT WHEN YOU'RE.
WE HAVE FEDERAL COMBINED HAVE
ASK IF EVER CALLED SEE HEARING
THAT IT WAS DONE MANY MANY YEARS
AGO BUT NOT ANYTHING IN RECENT
TIMES. I CERTAINLY COULD LOOK
INTO IT MOST MAJOR COMMUNITIES
TO SO THAT YOU KNOW CITY LA CITY
OF SACRAMENTO. OTHER MAJOR
BACHELOR IN THE WILDERNESS YES A
BILL TO IT THOUGH THAT THE BONTA
GRANTS OTHER WAYS. BUT IT'S IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE I DON'T
KNOW ESTADO AND IMPRESSION THE
UTILITY OF ANY OF THE.
HELICOPTER YEAH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
A VAN WORK FIVE PATROL FOR
THIRTY YEARS I'VE AND I KNOW THE.
THE VALUE AND IT'S VERY HIGH.
AND I DON'T OF WE'VE EVER DONE
THINGS LIKE THAT HELICOPTERS BUT
I KNOW WE HAVE BEEN THINGS LIKE
SWIMMING POOLS.
AND COMMUNITY CENTER NOT.
THANK YOU SIR.
AND SOME OF THEIR SPECIAL FUNDS
WE HAVE TO LOOK TO SEE TO THE
SOMETIMES THERE ARE SPECIAL
FUNDS. I DISCOVERED FOR.
.
THE VARIOUS THINGS LIKE THE SOON
TO THING THAT WE DID WAS THAT
OUT OF A SPECIAL FUNDS SO
SOMETIMES THERE.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH THE FUNDS
THAT EXISTS WITH THAT.
PEOPLE OF COLLECTED OVER THE
YEARS FOR VARIOUS KINDS ISSUES
KNOWS ISSUES CAPITAL AWAY IN THE
FUNDS FOR ME.
SO WE CAN ALWAYS INVESTIGATE AND
SEE IF THERE'S SOME THINGS THAT
DON'T PUBLIC SAFETY THAT MIGHT
HAVE SOME SPECIAL FUNDING FOR
THAT BUT ANYWAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMING. THINK IT'D
ALRIGHT I THINK THAT THAT IS ALL
OF OUR.
.
ISSUES AT WE HAVE MISTER STONE
TO VOTE AND.
SO WE WILL.
OTHER THAN THAT WE WILL THE
MEETING WILL BE ADJOURNED ONCE
WE DO THE VOTE FIVE A SYSTEM.
.
ARE YOU READY LISTA STONE.
GOOD.
OUR FIRST ITEM IS ISSUE ONE.
.
AND THAT'S THE CALIFORNIA COURTS
ORDER REGISTRY TO APPROVE AS
BUDGET OF THE VOTE CURRENTLY IS
FOR TWO.
FOUR ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER ONE ISSUE ONE.
STONE.
IT MAKES IT FIVE ZERO. OF THE
ITEM.
CONCERNING THE PROPOSAL MY WERE
THE RECOMMENDATION WAS TO REJECT
THAT CALIFORNIA COULD DEBT
CORPORATION EXPANSION THAT
VOTERS CURRENTLY TO TO.
TO WE WOULD WE REJECT THE
PROPOSAL OF TO SAYING THAT THEY
WANT TO FUND IT.
SO THEY VOTERS TO TO ENSURE
VOTE.
YEAH LIKE ABOUT WHAT IS IT ME.
THE MOTION IS NOT TO FUND THE
PROPOSAL.
JERRY JACK THE PROPOSAL FOR THE
CONVICTS.
OKAY THAT'S MAKES IT THREE TWO
SO THAT ITEM IS REJECTED.
OF THE NEXT PROPOSAL IS A. THE
MILITARY.
DEPARTMENT ITEM NUMBER THREE
THE VOTES ARE.
TO.
IN FAVOR OF IT TO NO VOTES.
AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS.
.
TO REIMBURSE THE AUTHORITY
OBJECT THE GENERAL
APPROPRIATIONS.
SO IT'S.
YEAH.
I THAT MAKES IT THREE TWO THAT
I'M ITEMS OUT.
OKAY.
THE REST OF THE IS THAT NEXT
ONE ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS ANTI
TRUST.
FOR THE WORKLOAD FOR THE DOJ TO
PROVE ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
AND I POSITIONS.
ONGOING OF THE ROLL CALL RIGHT
NOW IS TO TO.
STONE STONE.
YES IT IS TO PROVE IT YES.
OKAY I THAT'S THREE TWO THAT'S
OUT.
OF THE OTHER ITEMS ITEMS FIVE IS
THE OF YOUR OLD GAMBLING CONTROL
THAT VOTE RIGHT NOW IS FOUR ZERO.
I ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX THE SPRING
LETTER FROM TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS A TO DAM SAFETY
FUNDING.
THAT VOTE RIGHT NOW IS FORTY
ZERO.
WHAT I THAT'S FIVE OH?
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN IS THE SPRING
THAT IF A CHILD VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING FOR. OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO APPROVE AS
BUDGET AT THE ROLL CALL RIGHT
NOW IS FOUR ZERO.
OKAY VOTING I'VE THAT'S FIVE
ZERO THAT'S OUT.
ISSUE OF NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS
A SPRING LETTER RELOCATION OF
RED MOUNT TO COMMUNICATIONS SITE.
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT THE VOTE IS
CURRENTLY FOUR ZERO.
OKAY THAT'S FIVE ZERO IT'S OUT
OF ISSUE NUMBER NINE.
IS CALLED ADOPT THE PROVISIONAL
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE REGARDING
CORD HOLDING FACILITIES OF VOTE
RIGHT NOW IS FOUR ZERO.
FOR.
IT'S FIVE ZERO THAT'S OUT UP
ISSUE NUMBER OF NUMBER TEN.
DOT THE PROVISIONAL TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE REGARDLESS COURT
FEES SUNSET EXTENSION. OF ROLL
CALL THE ITEM IS CURRENTLY.
IN FAVOR OF THAT THAT'S TO TO
TO.
AYE ISSUE NUMBER TEN.
VOTE AYE THAT'S THREE TWO THAT'S
OUT.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN ADOPT THE
PROVISIONAL TRAILER BILL LETTING
SHOULD ARE THE SUNSET EXTENSION
OF THE COUNTY TO COUNTY TRANSFER
OF INMATES. THAT IS FOUR ZERO
RIGHT NOW.
MOVE OKAY THAT'S I'VE IT'S FIVE
ZERO THAT'S OUT AND THE LAST ONE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE ADOPTED
VISUAL TRAILER BILLINGS REGARD
THE TECHNICAL CLEAN UP. OF AB
FORTY ONE CHAPTER SIX NINETY
FIVE STATUE OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BUTTON CURRENT VOTE IS. TO TO TO.
OKAY I THAT MAKES A THREE TWO IN
THAT VOTE THAT ITEMS OUT.
OKAY IN THAT DISSOLVED VOTING
OKAY WOULD NOW ADJOURNED.
I'M SORRY LET ME GO BACK TO THE
LAST ITEM.
IT WAS IS TO TO NOT VOTING SO
IT'S THREE DID NOT VOTE INSIDE
THREE. EYES AND TO NOT VOTING
START BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU